foreign
[Music]
I am really working on doing intros with
context look at me big girl pants so
real quick context Nicole Amy Schreiber
brilliant comedian
uh uh producer writer on the only fans
the roasts that we're doing of me Bert
Kreischer she also uh organized my house
she's like my domestic dominatrix she's
like an incredible closet organizer
side note I've known her I met her once
when I was 18 through someone else so
she's known me for a very long time
we're both in the Dead Dog Club like
she's just the best one of the smartest
people I know funniest people stand up
comedian goes on the road with Dave
Attell
um genius she kind of like flirts in and
out with stand up but she's brilliant
stand up
and I'm trying to convince her to do her
own podcast but um I don't talk about
sex a lot which is so weird because I
think it's like I was I talk about sex
so much of my stand-up
uh and I've been shamed so much for
talking about sex like The Stereotype is
like oh women Comics just talk about
their vaginas they just talk about sex
it's cheap so I was like I'm gonna talk
about sex it cannot be cheap it has to
be the most well-crafted perfect joke to
earn the right to talk about this
low-hanging fruit pun intended so I
never talk and I'm also weirdly shy
about sex like you know I say things on
stage
to strangers I don't see the people that
come see me strangely assume as my
family but
like
I I say things to strangers I wouldn't
say to someone I'm in a relationship
with like I'm it's too embarrassing so
it's like it's like reading my journal
you know so I don't talk about sex and
interviews uh very much at all like I
have a little bit and I'm like
I think people want that like I love
call her daddy I love Alex Cooper and
I'm like oh she's doing like that's what
I I'd love to do that I'm just too
embarrassed like people love it she's so
I just don't I have too much shame like
embedded in me I'm too embarrassed and
I'm also like
yeah I just we have a different
background so I was like Nicole Amy
Schreiber had a podcast with porn stars
she's very like sexually
what's the word like
um Shameless has a negative connotation
like she's
like very sexually in her power she's
very like into she can enjoy sex in a
way that I like couldn't tell very
recently
so
uh we did a podcast that's just about
sex answering just sex like relentlessly
embarrassing honest
straight up like eye contact during a
blowjob type intimate
I don't want to cut like I think I
there's a couple things that I was like
let me just cut this and put it on my
only fans page because people are gonna
go out of their way to intentionally be
misunderstand what I'm saying in order
to justify being offended and like call
me a bad feminist is like talking about
like why is it hot when a guy rape rape
fantasies you it's like well it's not
actually rape because we're
together like it's already consensual
like
if a woman loves being like held down
and manhandled
like
that's hot and people go well that's not
good it's like well but it's not
if you're gonna criticize my Kink for
rape fantasy get me on the fact that I
love acting because we're acting
like we're acting we're like don't do
them like we're it's a it's a pla we're
in a play like we're acting alone we're
not it's not a real rape you know so
just even talking about that people just
and I don't blame them it's triggering
It's upsetting whatever but like stuff
like that where I'm like oh without the
nuance and the context this is gonna
just hurt people or upset people or make
people go like here's Whitney with her
rape jokes or whatever you know so it's
like there's some stuff that I just cut
out because it's like it's just goes in
the
um category of Life's too short or not
worth it or
I don't want someone to retweet this and
you don't follow me and then all of a
sudden you get ambushed with my me
talking about rape fantasies and it like
what that why that's hot or whatever
like from a primordial Reptilian Brain
like wanting to be dominated
so it's like you know
when he's trying to get attention she's
clickbait like whatever thing that
you're gonna think I'm doing I just want
to protect myself I have like I have to
protect myself you know so some of that
was cut and I'm gonna put on my only
fans page and I'm gonna protect myself
and others like I don't want someone
that's
you know not ready to hear that or
doesn't know who I am or doesn't know my
heart to like take that
um what is it when you take something
the wrong way but that means I'm blaming
you for taking it the wrong way I just
mean like you're it's gonna hit you
sideways and it as it should so
we get real granular
about orgasms and squirting and like
just I'm kind of dumb when it comes to
sex there's a lot I don't know like she
taught me a lot she's taught me so much
in my life she's just the most Alpha
fucking lead mayor
like I there's not a lot of people that
I really look up to like Nicole is one
of them and there's not a lot of people
who when they tell me to do something I
do it like she
I I don't mean like I'm a stubborn
asshole I just mean like uh like I
collect vintage shirts and I'm like I'll
use them at some point I'll give them as
a gift like I have all these vintage
shirts with wolves and horses on them
and she's like when's last time you wore
this and I'm like but I'm gonna and
she's like it go this is going and she
goes and donates it and gives it to them
charity of the um
uh like homeless women that need clothes
to go on job interviews and which is so
funny that they're all wearing like my
merch and a job interview
um but uh like she's
like
calls me out on my shit in a way that I
wish I I want to be able to call myself
out the way she calls me out like she's
like nothing gets past her
I just love her so much and I hope she
starts a podcast and I I kind of I don't
know
she's the greatest and you'll learn a
lot and this is like a great podcast for
all your girlfriends and all your guy
friends because we answer a lot of
questions I think guys are confused
about because no one fucking tells man
how to make women come no one tells them
so they're going to porn to be like what
huh so put on a yoga ball like it's like
no one's telling so I'm like this is
what works for me this is how I do it it
takes this you know it's like
so I think that it's um
again like in line of the kind of stuff
I want to make content-wise is always
like I just want to make what I would
would have wished was available to me
when I was 20. you know so like that's
the spirit of this
Nicole
[Music]
we're rolling what were you saying
Nicole I was saying I love to watch
Whitney Whitney you Whitney so well
um before the podcast I am a little busy
bee but you're always a busy bee you're
always just that you know I've said it
to you once before you need to learn how
to do nothing you don't that's the only
thing you don't know how to do is
nothing you know how to do everything
else you Whitney you haven't seen me
during sex I've
seen you sleeping pretty close literally
do nothing to really shine on your back
doing nothing um I remember when I came
over after you had been sick for maybe
like a week or so and you were like at
the most no energy I've ever seen you
and you were just on your back in bed
just withering away you lost like you
lost like 10 pounds in a week
um and you were like the that was the
only time I've ever seen you like with
no energy like just completely
surrendered or not doing anything and
you were doing that for about I don't
know like 15 20 minutes and then you
were like but I gotta go I gotta go move
shit gotta go do stuff category canals
yeah and you don't you don't stop you do
you keep going in a way that is
absolutely shocking and inspiring and I
want more of it in my life I want to dig
more into this first I am going to
introduce Nicole Amy Schreiber I've
Nicole I must say Nicole brilliant
comedian also organized my home my
domestic dominatrix
um chosen sister one of the funniest
people I know one of the only people
that I if they tell me to do something I
do it I'm probably the only person I'm
scared of uh the only person I respect
enough to uh acquiesce to
um the only person that can make me
throw away a vintage wolf shirt
is Nicole Amy and then if she won't let
me throw it away I'll just throw it away
and I'll just buy a new one yeah and
she'll she'll trusts me every time I
throw one away like 20 Papa it's like
you know when they say when you first
shave your legs they're like or JoJo's
gonna come back in thicker that's why I
I try to shave Whitney's face all the
time and then she just grows in a
complete beard and I have to be honest
with you you're probably the only person
that I have asked to be on this podcast
and you said no
I was just like no I just now I mean I
mean I wanted to say no this time too
but then I felt bad saying no twice and
the people pleaser part of me was just
like once is fine two times is kind of
rude and I just didn't want to be rude
because no one knows more about sex and
life in general than Amy uh I would say
Nicole Amy Schreiber a lot of people do
call you Amy a lot of people call me Amy
and I don't know why it is the absolute
weirdest thing that so many people call
you that that I start going like oh I
know what they mean so I'm like Amy or
yeah I answer to it now that's how often
it happens that I answer to it yeah it's
like me and Sarah Silverman I just
answer and um uh but you are one of the
only people that I genuinely ask advice
from you're one of the only people that
I like genuinely always want to talk
about sex stuff with and uh I figure why
not three years into this podcast
um actually give people what they want
which is talking about sex you never
talk about sex you know what's weird you
would think that that would be this
whole podcast and I think I do but for
some reason I'm like oddly shy about it
publicly when I'm not on stage yeah
isn't that weird that is weird I think
people think of me as like this comic
they're like well say anything about sex
and she talks about sex on stage but I
really don't on the podcast very often
I'm kind of shy and weird about it I'm
like I'm thinking back to the episodes
that I've listened to and like yeah I
mean you're a lot of the people you're
interviewing aren't like super
hypersexual people as well
but yeah it's also like noon like yeah
Houston Breeze promoting you know her
new show about the Holocaust yeah
do you like pegging yeah yeah you can't
talk pegging at one yeah it's just like
a little bit of it I think also because
I was told for so long like female comic
all you do is talk about sex and you
talk about your pussy and like that I
kind of was like oh I don't want people
to you know think I'm like leaning on
that or maybe people didn't like that
that before but then oh I'm getting
slaughtered right now in the comment
section on some of my Clips on social
media because I post I've been posting
clips and the sex stuff does the best so
I'm like I'm just gonna post the sex
jokes but it's they do the best because
people will start leaving horrible
comments and then the algorithms it up
what's wrong they're what they're just
obsessed I don't know women can't talk
about sex because
you know uh female comedians all they do
is talk about sex and in this one joke I
never even said the word sex yeah
um I can't even remember uh oh I was
talking about mom jeans and how they
make your pussy look huge yes yes
um and it's like someone's like I'm like
I never see it even said the word sex
and they're like no women did all they
do is talk about sexual things I'm like
oh so if I just even mention a body part
that's just too much you do is think
about sex when we're talking yeah you
know what I mean but just fine too you
know I mean we are holding a giant
phallus up to our mouth yeah and we're
we're listen there's nothing we're gonna
do uh we could come in wearing bag head
to toe and a man will find a way to
sexualize us and it's also uh as a
female comic it's like maybe this goes
for male Comics too but it's like okay
you don't want me to talk about sex you
want me to talk about politics yeah yeah
that's why you want my hot take on you
know what okay I'm not gonna talk about
my pussy anymore I'm gonna start telling
people how to vote how about that
this is my thing it's like okay I have a
I have a very fun Act of sex life
you talk about what you know and if you
don't want to hear me talk about sex
that must mean you're not having sex or
you're having bad sex so it's making you
uncomfortable that I'm having a part of
very fulfilling part of my life that you
don't have at all you do have a uh like
I am like to think I'm pretty
um what is the word um when it comes
about sadly I don't think I get a shame
about it you know I I definitely I I
didn't have shame until I became a comic
yeah because then I got hyper aware of
how much I talk about it because you're
like oh you just you're leaning on the
fact that you have a pussy and you're
just talking about sex and like that's
cheating and stuff like that which is
like if you think that even talking
about
sex on stage makes stand up any easier
oh yeah yeah it makes it so much harder
because you have to have twice as smart
a joke you have to be twice as Alpha you
have to it doesn't matter but the point
is
um you know you are one of the few
people that I get a little bit shy
around because you are so I think you're
the person people think I am yeah when
it comes to that probably so you had a
podcast about sex we're gonna answer all
of your sex questions here shortly this
is the only truly I don't even go to
WebMD about am I squirting from the
right place yeah like I will literally
just ask you I'm I'm your sexipedia
um I had a podcast where I interviewed
it was called love her uh and it was a
podcast where I interviewed porn stars
yeah but it was specifically about
fetish yes foot fetish okay because the
company love her feet.com sponsored my
podcast okay so it was very much just
interviewing
um porn stars who partake specifically
in foot fetish porn
um and what I learned is that a lot of
the fans in foot fetish are huge
assholes
um I I I stopped It ultimately because
it was just it was too much well let me
ask you something because isn't the peop
the fans of it and by that you mean the
the male fans the male fans so isn't
part of the foot fetish thing not that
I'm not pro
um uh being attracted to the parts of
women's bodies that we think are the
ugliest you know I think there's
something really like you know know it's
like we're running around trying to be
thin for men trying to be free for men
and they're just like give me your
athlete's foot I want your fucking
callus but isn't there something about
that that is uh people that like to be
humiliated and denigrated therefore they
probably have such low self-esteem
therefore they're probably gonna
thousand percent so it's one of those
things where it's like you know they'll
they'll say don't King Shame but like
part of the Kink is the shame so it's
like how can you not Kink shame it's
like that what if what if just being
shamed for your Kink is your kick like
then you like what am I gonna deprive
you of your king
um which is by such a big part of like
some of the like guys that have done uh
you know let me think of a word that's
good sorry guys I just woke up from a
nap was in Sacramento for four days
super Thai Thai when a man in I'm um I'm
not talking about rape I'm not talking
about you know for sexual assault what
would a man in Hollywood or whatever
business sort of does shows or dick or
whatever sometimes that Kink is a woman
going ugh gross yeah and then we cancel
them publicly and we're like oh you're
just giving him the biggest orgasm yeah
the biggest organs all he wants is for
you to make absolute shit out of him and
yeah there are guys who want that and
it's like then what do you do with that
no no that you can't just ignore it
because it's a problem but it it it's
interesting I in the process of doing
that entire podcast like my love for uh
women in porn and just sex workers in
general is it's endless I mean they are
some of the most intelligent fascinating
women I have ever met and now you're
making shows for only fans and I mean
how how much I love that you're making a
show on only fans is it has changed the
lives of women around the world in in
unbelievable ways it has made women who
had absolutely nothing who had
potentially a future just full of
struggle and by the way even if like for
a year just needed to temporarily get
out of a bad relationship teachers that
their options are either going to school
to teach elementary and maybe getting
mowed down by Machine Gun yeah they get
to own only fans make a little more
money they're either way they're getting
shot in the face yeah you know I mean
take a hot load or take a you know a hot
machine gun load either way you're
taking a load yeah yeah and so it's just
to see like and to watch Hollywood be
like Ugh only fans but it's like this
has already paid more women yeah than
you pretend you're gonna pay women like
this fucking this bullshit Hollywood
where like and we hire women and we give
money to women and we're gonna
redistribute the wealth it's like where
is it yeah where you know women are
making so much more money on only fans
the only woman I know who gives more
jobs to women than only fans is you
the writer's room for the first for the
for your roast was just like all women I
know we've every comedian and female
comedian in Hollywood is on the same
cycle yeah on the same cycle it was just
us bleeding in a room together watching
Whitney eat eggs and cheese it was
pretty much I love being in a room with
10 female comedians like you no shit
slides like not one thing that's right
and every when I'm in the writer's room
I get very feral and I get very um I I
really try to conserve my mental energy
and avoid uh decision fatigue so I
remember there was hard-boiled eggs in
the fridge and I and I took out the eggs
and I started putting cream cheese on
them with my fingers and just eating
them like a snake and and as soon as I
got to the second bite I was like okay
like literally eight of the funniest
women I know are watching this I'm about
to get everyone's everyone's about to
roast you by the way I figured it out
you eat I feel like you
you eat like a kid who's just been told
they can run into the kitchen and eat
whatever they want but they have five
five seconds to get it yes but that's
how you eat every every meal is like
just you like this this this this and
then just throwing it together like
you're a poor kid in a dorm room I also
believe that you know how uh people when
they decorate their apartment or
something they're like as long as I like
it it will all match yeah sometimes it
works sometimes it really doesn't work
with food it's like everything I like
goes together in my head like I love
cream cheese I love eggs so together
yeah you know but I just I have a I you
know it's like you really
I mean it was room temperature cream
cheese so it was easier to spread but
like you really just buttered it yeah
yeah yeah like it's it's really it's a
it's an interesting thing to watch you
eat you take a bite and then put the
cream cheese in and fill the bite like a
Cadbury Creme Egg it's like a Cadbury
Cream Egg that's just real egg and
cheese it's disgusting yeah and my dad
used to make growing up I don't know if
it's a poor thing or a southern thing or
just a him thing but he used to make us
scrambled eggs and instead of with like
cheddar cheese he would put Philadelphia
Cream Cheese in it and it's delicious
there's um I worked at a restaurant on
Melrose and they used to make a a
Scramble with Philadelphia cream cheese
unlocks it's delicious and I don't know
again I don't know if this is a dad
thing my dad had a couple combos that
will blow your mind one was peanut
butter and mayonnaise sandwiches we used
to eat them all the time after this
podcast we are good do you have
mayonnaise I might do a peanut you have
definitely a peanut butter
organized uh I organized your pantry so
I know that there's peanut butter but
we're gonna go make that we're gonna try
delicious yeah it is like the perfect
little tang with the sweetness I
absolutely don't believe you that sounds
that sounds like something you would eat
on Fear Factor truly that app that
sounds beyond disgusting and I can't
believe your father fed that to you
that's child abuse and I've heard about
your childhood that's the most abusive
thing that happened to you one thousand
percent
your father sounds like a monster and I
love how these somehow Bamboozled you
into thinking like this is good that is
some poor shit he's like I can't afford
good food so I'm just gonna make you eat
mayonnaise and peanut butter and think
I'm just like a fun dad oh that's
terrible he's like I don't know how to
make her love me I'm just gonna settle
for Stockholm syndrome yeah
it's all about everything my dad said he
would feed me food tell me to do
something and the reason was always it
builds character and I always went with
it I never challenged it one time you
know the episode you just did with
Diablo Cody you were talking about how
your dad would like wake you up in the
middle of the night and like make you
take a quiz oh yeah I was listening to
that and I was like her dad fully
prepared her for like some sort of
mental war in life that I ended up being
drafted to you were drafted to and you
you just you killed it you would
whatever this war is like I'm your your
father truly did if that is how he
helped us establish like a work ethic
and like to be ready for anything at any
point like
I mean you you said it you know a lot of
therapists are like this was really bad
Whitney and I'm like listening to it I
was like that's not that I don't know I
don't know I don't know there's no other
explanation for my career there's except
that I mean it is it is unbelievable to
watch I no no one I have ever met in
Hollywood Works harder than you not one
fucking person not even fucking close
you know what I my dad it's interesting
because you know we have a lot of God
I'm gonna try to say this delicately we
have a lot of guy friends uh you know
whether it's male Comics just you know
people in our Lives who pull a lot of
chicks get a lot of strange they're very
charismatic that is strange
and uh they're just ax wound hoarders
and a lot of charismatic man my dad was
incredibly charismatic he looked like
Dan Aykroyd he used to sign autographs
as Dan Aykroyd so many people would run
up to him and he like didn't want to
break their hearts it's like where I
learned codependent so he would just
sort of pretend to be Dan Aykroyd to try
to make the person's day sign an
autograph I was like 12 when I learned
my dad was not Dan awkward like it was
devastating like my dad's a movie yeah I
wasn't devastated when I found out and
because I would always go to the uh get
in trouble for lying at school about
being like my dad was one of the was
conehead's guy like he was in The Blues
Brothers and they're like you can't
you're a liar and I just I didn't you
know but he women loved him I mean like
loved him I remember like as when I was
a kid would be at restaurants and like
the waitresses would like come over all
they would sit with us and like just you
know and I think by the time I was born
uh my dad knew like he didn't go oh
things are gonna be different than the
way the world is uh men are with women
his thing was always like this he leaned
into the sexism of the world maybe
because he was him and he know how he
saw women or whatever but he was like
you're always gonna have to work twice
as hard to get half as far it's never
going to be fair he never he always said
life's not fair he goes so yes you can
memorize all the answers to all these
questions but what if you're hungry what
if you don't get food what if there's a
flood what if you know the person next
to you you've got to be able to work
totally so that was his whole thing he
was it's not good enough to be able to
do this under perfect circumstances you
have to be able to do it with I mean I
mean it's kind of brilliant and he's
like you're gonna have to be twice as
good because you're a girl he like
drilled that into me did your dad ever
talk to you about because you were a
very beautiful uh a beautiful kid
um and I feel like you know you I not to
like keep going back to the Diablo Cody
by the way it was literally one of my
favorites it was a good that was a good
episode really good I mean she is just
she's a great interview she's just Star
Struck by her I was very nervous she's
phenomenal but but you were talking
about like being you know sexualized as
a Catholic school girl right um and you
know I knew you when you were in high
school and like you were and polls known
me longer than literally anyone yeah
yeah she actually is the age she said
she is I know um I'm as surprised as you
are I know trust me that is the one
thing anytime I say that I've known you
since you were 17 people are like is she
really I'm like yes she really is why is
this ever every single time it's the
only thing people want to know
um uh but you you know you were like
crazy pretty when you were younger
that's really nice did was by the way I
put my baby picture behind you finally
because everyone thinks I've had so much
plastic surgery done and that don't you
look at the same that baby I had I have
plastic surgery face like even when I
was a kid I looked like I had had bad
like filler I mean
I do I don't know she looked she I
remember we went to a bar when we we
when you were visiting we have a mutual
friend my friend from who I grew up with
Tracy Harnish and they did the summer
program and then Whitney came to visit
at UCLA so people who are like oh you
know how did you make in this business
so fast like I was plotting and planning
and strategizing and calculating from
when I was a senior in high school I
came out to LA I interned I did the UCLA
theater program like I was like
like any good comedian I do not take no
for an answer from men or women yep
um but you so you did that program and
then you came to visit that summer but I
remember we went to a bar and I remember
everybody had fake ID
um and we were or I knew someone at the
bar so we didn't need fake ID or I can't
even remember but everybody was getting
carded at some point and then you reject
micromanagement is she blocking her face
with her hand her beautiful face with
her beautiful hand occasionally oh sorry
no don't just like here okay
um so I remember you didn't get carded
oh like you is people always thought I
was 15 years older than I was but you
just you had like just a mature face and
you just carried yourself in a mature
way I don't even remember you being that
funny like I remember you being funny I
remember you being a good hang but you
were like a very like very serious like
pulled together like it was shocking to
me because Tracy was a hurricane of a
human yeah I was also that way and you
were just like very poised very like put
together and it's like was that like a
trauma response from like
like is did your dad teach you to be
that way like where did you learn to be
like such a together like young lady
like it was shocking to me dude it's
adult child of alcoholic 101. it's like
when you have alcoholism in your house
and people are preoccupied with their
addictions or they're passed out early
because they've been drinking or
whatever it's like you just have to
become precocious because you have to
just take care of yourself like I didn't
know any different like I was like
packing my own school lunches when I was
in third grade I was making myself
dinner it was like I yeah it's like
stuff like that where it didn't I didn't
know it was any different you know like
it's when you're um when you think you
live in a mansion until you go to a
friend's house or you maybe that's why
you're such a weird eater because there
was never an adult to teach you how to
eat no you were just left to your own
devices and that's all you ever learned
I would like improvise I was making like
a like a a healthy remember the Healthy
Choice meals you would microwave I was
like making my own I would just have to
improvise what what with whatever was in
the house and something I didn't learn
until very recently and I did just did
an episode of that show physical on
Apple which is sort of about women and
the 80s that had these eating disorders
and the height of exercise and you know
my mom you know was in fashion and she
was incredibly thin she was 100 pounds
we would have in the wine and artichokes
that's all we had on the fridge I
thought that was normal wow you know so
it's like you just yeah I and then I was
modeling at a young age where you kind
of just have to sort of yeah in order to
get the job that you want or that you
need because you need money I remember I
would have to kind of just like act
older than I was in order to get a
maternity catalog job you know you kind
of just try to act a little bit older I
guess I was always dating older guys
which I'm working on this bit that I do
not know if it's gonna ever fly but I
really want to make it work about how
you know um because it's such a nuanced
thing of like I feel like such a big
part of my success in life this is gonna
get me in so much fucking trouble just
saying is that like when you grow up
poor like parents aren't that upset
about their younger daughters dating
older guys no it's not I'm not saying 14
year old should date 30 year olds I'm
just saying when I was 17 8 I was dating
35 year olds because their thing is like
okay can you pick you up from school can
you pick you up from school can you
throw you some money like can he take
off all all the things that are
burdening me and my life with you having
to pick you up having to be there for
you having to pay things for you oh so
now there's a sugar daddy coming into
the picture who's by the way just gonna
help out like he's you're not gonna
marry him who knows anyone can get you
pregnant 18 or 35 like if you're someone
if you're a mom to an 18 year old would
you rather your daughter be dating
another 18 year old who's gonna give
your child tetanus with his braces
trying to eat her pussy who's going to
take pictures of her and show his
friends and probably like cheat on her
and give her you know no whatever and
make her eat a tide pod for a tick tock
video or some 35 year old or 30 or 35
feels too old like you know who has a
car who can pick her up who's like you
know take off some of the burden
absolutely I don't know I mean I'm sort
of like there are a lot of parents who
would turn a blind eye to that yeah I
think that my I think that my parents
are very much like either way it sucks
to have your daughter get fucked by like
either way it's a nightmare yeah at
least have her fuck someone who can pay
for the abortion exactly you know so we
don't have to pay for it exactly like a
rich guy will take care of that quickly
quietly no offense or bus and I'm not
saying it's the right thing now just
because there's so much access to other
people you know it was just sort of you
know I think it there was an innocence
to it more 20 years ago than there is
now because like when I meet girls that
are 18 now I'm like you're so young like
you are so when I was 18 I was kind of
already had been working in New York and
I was traveling to New York on my own
and I was like out now La for like I
don't know I just had a little bit more
well I think I think the the like the
young girls that I see like the young
girls here in La it's like really
shocking to me how mature they are yeah
like I don't remember anyone being but
those are the ones that you're meeting
yeah they're probably already hanging
out with older people you know yeah like
when I go on the road and sometimes I
meet 17 18 years I'm like you're so
you're so young you're so young yeah no
when my when my goddaughter moved out to
LA she's now 24.
um when she moved out to L.A she moved
out when she was 18.
um and she was like hanging around with
all of these girls and she was like
telling me like all these girls they all
have like sugar daddy yes they all you
know and she was like should I do it I
want to get the you know they all have
these like really nice Handbags and I'm
like no you should not do that like if
you need a handbag like go get a job
yeah you don't need a YSL handbag when
you're 18. that's the dumbest thing I've
ever heard yeah it's ridiculous but it's
like the whole value structure changes
in this city but like when she was like
in Michigan like she was just like a
very sweet innocent girl yeah I also
think that like you know this is like a
little bit of a theory I'm working on so
excuse me if it's wobbly and we're gonna
get to your sex questions don't panic
which is like I kind of think these days
you're a little bit the age that you
want to be like you can kind of choose
your level of maturity because I've been
you know everyone knows I dated a
younger guy you know um uh there's
another younger guy that I've been then
seeing and the younger guys come at me
like I'm stunned that they but these
younger guys that come up listening to
you know Rogan and Segura and Tom and
like they're sitting around and they're
getting all this wisdom from their
Elders I mean it's kind of the new
sitting around the fire that's really
really interesting with the tribe it's
like they're hearing about marital
problems they're hearing about this is
what I did wrong in my 20s this is what
I would do differently and I meet these
guys that are in their you know um late
20s or early 30s and there's so much
more mature than the guys I know that
are in their late 40s
that is that is shocking to me to hear
that like I I never thought of it that
way but that's absolutely what it is
they are being parented they're
listening all these different older men
and and and learning from all of their
experiences and yeah that will make you
mature I mean it's like in the same way
that like you know a young woman could
listen to you and like the things you
have to say about like which was exactly
the point career of me doing a podcast
writing the book was going I just want
to make the podcast and write the book
that I wish was available to me when I
was 20 because I wanted to grow up I
wanted to be mature I didn't want to be
an idiot but like where do you get like
how like there's no school for that
there's no pill for that you know you
just have to go and get life experience
but like this is the thing I do love
about podcasts is like you can you know
guys listening to you know Lex Friedman
and huberman and Rogan and whatever and
like I mean every guy I meet they're
like oh you know I don't drink anymore
it's been two years you know I started
with silver October and I just kept
going with it I have not met a guy
that's in their late 20s that watches
porn in a while they're all like I don't
do porn anymore I'm hanging out with
them I
these are the guys that I date yeah yeah
and but is that I mean I'm exaggerating
that's everyone and I'm sure some lie
whatever but they're like oh no what it
does to your brain is terrible and I
want to be able to enjoy sex and they
say they only watch porn to learn like
moves I mean I've I've really never
spoken to that many guys about porn and
what they know
um and what they learn from it like I've
never like the conversations that you're
describing I've never had conversations
with guys like that it's really nice to
know that they're out there you know
like learning those things I didn't know
that that's that that was like you know
in the Zeitgeist now uh that porn rots
your brain and guys are actually taking
it responsibly now and then I think a
lot of guys started you know at least
Smart Ones Will of course correct on
their own like yeah you know this
younger guy I was talking to and like he
was like yeah I just couldn't get hard
anymore he was like what I needed when
you're on the 47th page of fisting
you're like hold on you'd have to be
mentally handicapped to not be like
something's wrong here you know I and I
think guys biggest fear is being with a
woman and his dick not working so like
if I can't get my dick hard off of this
like triple pen MILF you know step
brother family reunion or whatever
um what's going to happen with I'm with
a girl who's just naked what if I just
know by the way sidebar did you know
that during the pandemic
um uh uh incest porn like stepbrother
stepsister porn was that was the biggest
searched category that was the most
popular form of porn during the pandemic
okay so basically everybody was just
sitting around at home looking at their
families and being like and then going
is this the line being like watching
people fucking their families well it is
weirdly erotic to see people in masks
yeah also there's
but I think that's like about like
incestors this might be our only option
what if we never get out yeah what if we
never got it here I'd fuck my stepmom
absolutely yeah I mean if if left our
own device says we'd all be fucking
everybody I want to ask more about that
because first of all there's something
hilarious about right now and I don't
know why maybe it's because I'm just
like when I was at my ostensible hottest
let's say like whatever even it's
socially constructed I think by the way
you and I look better than we've ever
looked I think we look right I think
we're the hottest we've ever been but
when you're in your 20s that's when
people like that's your you know your
tight skin years whatever and of course
that's when we think we're our hottest
but we hate ourselves at least who cares
but the point being
um hold on where was I going with that
oh I think there was something around
that where I'm like okay I'm obsessed
with my appearance I had all these
Eating Disorders I thought I had to be
perfect I thought my tits had to be
perfect my pussy had to be shaved
perfectly whatever and then as I get
older now I thought like okay in the
back of my mind like when I turned 40
I'll at least be like on the bench like
I'll at least be like not have to deal
with like male attention anymore trying
to get guys to think I'm hot trying
whatever and I feel like it's totally
opposite I feel like we got younger guys
now well first of all MILF porn is
number one search totally yeah so I'm
like you're telling me it's I'm just
getting hotter as I get older this is
exhausting I I more guys hit on me now
than ever have well I think younger guys
also are more confident than when we
were younger yeah like I don't I think
younger guys have this crazy level of
confidence that is just astounding to me
I think younger guys like older women
well I think younger I think everybody
has mommy and daddy issues and it's just
like they're gonna figure that shit out
with us I'm big mommy energy Marilyn
ricegum you know younger dudes all all
up in her business too and it's like I'm
my problem is I'm just not into younger
guys like I've I definitely have like my
daddy issues go in the direction of like
I want to be with an older guy but I
think that I want to be with an older
guy that's always been my my thing but
maybe it's just of living in La older
guys don't always mean more mature older
guys don't always mean shit I just want
shit together I don't care how old you
are what's hot to me is you having your
shit together yes but older guys in LA
are different than older guys in other
cities yeah older guys in L.A like I you
know it's like I don't I don't I don't
know we cannot leave out yeah tools of
New York the tools of New York and the
tools men in New York have this Peter
Pan shit of like I'm 55 I'm still
wearing a hoodie and a Patagonia vest to
work and I'm still gonna date NYU
students even though I'm gonna give them
the worst dick of their life the worst
dick of their life like absolutely
unequivocally like the only way those
dudes are getting hard is from a fucking
truckload of Viagra and they're all on
testosterone they just watch American
Psycho the scene where Christian he's
looking at himself in there that's what
he jerks off to every night and then
goes out and fucks chicks and thinks
about that scene and not even the check
um it is dating right now is so weird
for me right now how do you start is it
app hinge apps hinge Raya
um I hate Bumble like let's shut the
fuck up I'm not talking to the guy first
no you you talk I showed up with the
vagina the man has to talk first these
are the rules I don't I know Bumble
works for a lot of people that godspeed
I'm glad I need such an intense Alpha
yeah that if I initiate I will just
never get wet ever I will never help me
like just say fucking hell do it just
something just say the bare minimum but
but I and what you're saying about like
being an alpha like I think being an
alpha we are alphas in our career every
day yeah like we are elfing doing our
own thing and it's just like we've also
been you know you've had relationships
along the way I've had relationships
along the way but for the most part like
we've just been taking care of ourselves
yes we don't need someone to rescue us
we don't need someone to you know you
have the house on the hill you own it
like it's like you don't need someone
but you need a man to show up in the
only way a man can show show up is just
say fucking hello yeah make a fucking
effort like that is that is the bare
minimum I could ask of you as a man and
by the way it's not about like
contributing financially it's not about
that kind of stuff I think it's about
you know um Kevin Christie said this
once and it was the hottest thing I've
ever heard he is one of my best platonic
guy friends but he said he goes it is a
man's job to be useful and I know that
that probably sounds for a lot of people
like it's a woman's job to be in the
kitchen it's a woman's job to carry
children whatever but I think that like
he he just put it in a way that helped
me understand because I had become so
independent that I was not making space
for the type of man that I wanted which
is a man that is useful because I didn't
come off like I needed anything so I was
actually attracting men that needed
Mommy Mommy when in reality I needed
Daddy Daddy and I had this is why that
book that I know it's such a toxic title
it's so fucking backwards but it works
which is the book getting to I do which
the whole conceit of it is like um
there's someone has to be the masculine
and someone has to be the feminine we
can't fluctuate back and forth to
masculine and feminine because there's
no way to choreograph it so it's like
someone has to be the giver and someone
has to be the receiver and in my
personal life I am so wildly traditioned
and submissive when I'm just like
literally Wrap Me In duct tape and hang
me from the deck as you're cleaning the
gutters and I by the guy that you're
seeing right now is taking notes he's
like duct tape gutters
I got a pulley for that perfect like
just and I I do I am the kind of person
that by the time I ask you to do
something I think I could have just done
it which means I don't so then I don't
uh allow the man to even be the alpha
because I'm like by the time and I'm
gonna be a shrill cunt if I ask you and
I feel like I'm being bossy and I've had
guys before be like I'm not your
assistant why are you treating me like
that so I feel embarrassed in that but
it's like basic stuff but you have to
let him do it for you and the guys that
I can really
date are the ones where I'm like oh I
got it and he goes no you don't
you know I mean the ones that don't
because I'll pick up the bag I'll open
the door myself he'll go no no I got it
and I'll go I got it and go I got it
yeah you know yeah I need someone to
come I need someone to yes you need
someone to Alpha out Alpha yeah yes yes
and it's listen like I I love I love
that you can do it's not that you can't
like when you're saying I got it you do
got it but don't let me emasculate you
yeah you have to don't let me masculate
you and it's also like I you know it's
like you and I talked about this a few a
few months ago where we were talking
about like who are you gonna date like
who the fuck are you gonna date like you
swing such a big fucking clit like like
you swing the biggest fucking clip like
but you also know me and you also know
I'm just like I also know that you're
like a huge softie and you just need
someone I think that's one of the
reasons why you like it when I Alpha you
uh is just because you're just like oh
finally I like don't have to be
I don't have to be the most competent
person in the room I don't have to be
the person who's doing everything and
executing and making everything happen
and I think you know can we talk about
the guy that you're seeing yeah I mean
so the for example like the person that
you're seeing right now like he is
showing up for you and being useful for
you in like very Like Loving masculine
ways that is like
exactly what you need
like it's such a huge thing for you to
just to watch you kind of like
relinquish control and let someone do
something for you but you know what else
there's a difference between someone
doing something for you because they
think they have to to be with you and
someone that truly gets off on it
thousands and this person truly gets off
on it yeah whereas before it's like I
know this person's just doing this
because they they think they have to
compromise in order to be with me they
have to do this like I feel guilty and I
know that this is going to breed
resentment and down the line it's I'm
this person's keeping score and the
downlines are like well I fucking
cleaned up yeah and I was like Oh I
thought you were doing it because you
actually enjoyed doing it but turns out
you were keeping score and then I
totally shut down and go hyper
independent and don't want to ask for
anything because it feels like no you
need steeped in codependent you need
someone whose Love Languages acts of
service and that is just what they do
they love to love you that way and
that's what this person is doing like
I'm also like that too with god with
guys sexually and otherwise like but I
don't but if the other person's keeping
score I just get you know okay well
let's go on to that now that you've
brought up
you guys have okay a couple things first
of all you have um uh you guys sent in a
bunch of questions I'm gonna answer
these but I feel like we should start
with a basic question that I have asked
you before of I am still confused about
orgasms like I'm could I I've only I've
had an orgasm very few times from a
wiener in my vagina that just is hitting
a part where and it it fucked up my L4
permanent I mean I had to be on top in a
chair is the only way I can do it it
happened like twice wait a minute I'm
sorry on top in a chair were you fucking
in a birthing chair what do you mean on
top in a chair like he was sitting on a
chair I had to straddle him and like it
was degrading what how much by the way I
just proposed a scenario of fucking in a
birthing chair and I'm just like oh my
God that would be really fucking hot we
have a friend who has a uh a bed that's
one of those medical beds with um
stirrups and you can use a remote to
move it up and down and she moves her
undercarriage and her boyfriend just
fucks her in it oh I need to I can't
wait to talk about who this is I can't I
I mean that's the level that I want to
get to yeah that's the only reason I
want money it's a very good friend of
ours okay good because now I need to
know exactly I think about it kind of a
lot because now I'm gonna have to tell
her the birthing chair is an option
because she can just sit in the birthing
chair and he can just lay on the ground
underneath her and just thrust up well
so I I don't even know how it happened
and I've never been able to do it again
but it was like I was like 24 I was like
you know my achilles heels were in
better shape I guess but I had to sit on
top of him and kind of do it myself but
it took 40 minutes and then by the time
you like feel the orgasm coming like I
just hand on his face like shut the fuck
up oh yeah there's no way if I'm gonna
have an orgasm that way I can never
respect him again afterwards okay wait I
need to know about the logistics of this
really quickly okay so you're in a chair
what kind of chair was was it um it was
in a rehearsal for an acting class oh my
God wait is this does this do the acting
teacher who fucked you up uh yes this
was the acting teacher that tried to
convince me I was molested more than I
was even molested like that one no
by the way I love the fact that there's
so many oh that's not the acting
teachers I'm like how many predatory
acting teachers are there like all of
them
um every single one nobody becomes an
acting teacher because they're not
trying to prey on young hot women oh
yeah 100 period 100 I look back at that
and I'm just like that was just like a
giant weird like Kink Festival where
it's like do the scene from Streetcar
Named Desire where he rapes you in the
acting teachers like you know what let
me I'll just do it with you real quick
and then you start crying more and he's
like she's fucking crying oh yes he like
wipes the tears off your face and then
he like puts it in his pocket so he can
masturbate why am I doing the scene in
the bathroom from The Basketball Diaries
oh my God like this doesn't feel right
um but yeah no there is an acting class
uh School in LA and I'm not afraid of
Scientology and I'll call those
motherfuckers out all the time but it's
like rooted in like a scientist it's
like a Scientology like feeder
um class yeah but that happened one time
but the only other way that I know how
to have orgasms is uh clitoral by saying
that okay and there's the outside kind
in the inside there's outside kind of
inside kind so they say there's three I
mean there's probably more I'm not like
a actual physiological sexual expert
um Mo Mendel though is married to a sex
actor no way yeah he's he's um uh I
can't remember hilarious comic but she's
momentous super funny but his wife who's
pregnant right now um but yes she knows
if you want to have like a real fucking
like sex expert like physical sex expert
um I can just I've just fucked a lot so
so I just have I just have that Real
World Experience
um
I'm like a car that's been test driven
like a lot and I don't even know
um an anal Anthropologist perfect I am
an anthropologist
um so um but outside orgasms outside so
there's when you imagine you're just
using your hand to make a clitoral
orgasm to clitoral orgasm so I mean I
can't I can't come from just clitoral
stimulation I have to with your hand
with I cannot with just my hand I have
to have a car parked in the garage like
I have to have something inside my
vagina okay always like I can't just
it's never like something just needs to
be in that space yeah yeah
um it's I can't I can't have an empty
parking spot yeah so car always in the
garage and then masturbate now once you
like so there's physically occupying the
space of the vagina and then inside
there's this I mean I never done you I'm
gonna just Dom your one I'm sorry let's
use that one yeah so inside uh there's
the G-Spot on the inside which is when
you if you like I don't think I know
where mine is it's like if you so if
you're fucking on the inside it's like
right up it's in here it's like when it
hooks around so that's why when when if
a guy wants to make you squirt or come
he's supposed to become hither motion
come hither scoop towards
cut your nails and wash your hands yeah
yeah oh God please guys
get rid of the hangnails wash your hands
wash your hands I I cannot I haven't
broken away to the camera for this long
guys wash your hands please for the love
of God don't come near us with your
filthy and if you think like oh I
watched them earlier I don't know you
wash your hands and then you come touch
my pussy that's the only time you get to
touch my pussy is once you've got
nothing hotter to me than a guy you're
hooking up kissing kissing he'll push
you on the bed and you're like get over
here what are you doing he goes to the
bathroom washes his hands while he's
looking at you to let you know uh like I
got these digitalis are clean because
otherwise this is You're Gonna Lose
because all I'm thinking about is I
don't want to ask someone to wash his
hands then I'm going to be being
dominant and I just want to be
submissive and then I don't want him to
think that I have a weird dirty pussy
that gets UTIs and then the entire time
I'm gonna be thinking about getting a
UTI I'm not gonna be able to focus and
then as soon as sex is over I'm gonna
fucking run and try to pee as quickly as
possible also wash your mouth out before
you go down on us I'm not saying come
like with like
Listerine breath like come right to my
pussy like just give that mouth a little
rinsearoo before you like go down there
because your mouth is also a bacteria
pit um correct like there's just so many
listen I know sex is gross and dirty and
like that's how I like it but like also
like wash your hands the more you just
wash your hands before the dirtier it
can be and also you never get to go from
tushy if you're gonna go to tushy ATM
you're at tushy I mean you can't go you
can't go what do we what do we say a to
A to B asked to put something you can't
go you go pussy to ask if once you go to
ass that's that's yeah it's only if
you're in porn can you do back and forth
because those girls have cleaned their
assholes out like a whistle oh God I got
it got it that's pretty much it and also
those girls are getting paid a lot of
money to have
um BB so totally and they probably have
like a game plan they've got yeah
they've dealt with that like a million
standing by yes
they are pussy Pros hey y'all so as I
my personal experience of moving through
the world and uh you know supporting
family members in their medical needs I
really found myself being like well just
get on Zach talk and it's this is true I
have a lot of family members that didn't
have health insurance now kind of do
whatever that are having health problems
my family is getting older and they're
like well I'm like you need to go to
doctor get that checked out and they're
like well I have to call I'm like ZocDoc
there's a sponsor on my podcast I'm
telling you this is a Genius app ZocDoc
is a free app that shows you doctors who
are patient reviewed take your insurance
and are available when you need them go
to zocdoc.com Whitney and download the
ZocDoc app for free I'm serious for your
family members that are like their big
excuse is like I don't know I have to go
to a doctor and what if they don't take
like zoc Doc like it's actually a life
hack
then start your search for a top rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours no excuses that's zoc doc z o c
d o c.com slash Whitney
and here's what I'm realizing if you are
not taking care of yourself
you're abusing your children I swear to
God this is my new thing is like people
that don't have kids that don't go to
the doctor
you're giving your future kid
a shittier life because you're not
taking care of yourself because they're
gonna have to take care of you
know what I'm saying like when you the
people you love suffer when you don't go
to the doctor because we have to hear
about it we have to worry about you
we're gonna get whatever disease you
have you know like
so I'm big on like ZocDoc go Sock Doc
that shit like I'm not I didn't I don't
deserve this like you not going to the
doctor is not you hurting yourself it's
hurting the people around you also is
that like a really hot take
stockdoc.com Whitney if they're still a
sponsor
manscaped you guys you guys ho ho ladies
Naughty or Nice tis the season for your
man to perform and I'm not talking about
gift giving okay there's no two ways to
skin a cat
you know what I mean this is not the
saying and there's only one way to shave
there is only one way to shave your
balls
so I this is not the way they want me to
endorse this is my guess but shocker
manscape is so good I use it
it's like member secret strong enough
for a man pH balance for a woman I'm
like this is perfect for a man but good
enough for a woman like I literally use
this deodorant
um the guy that I am currently has have
taken as a lover he has these fucking
what is it with you guys where you shave
but you don't shave your upper cheek
like you'll shave down on here and then
there'll be like a bunch of long hairs
like right on your um What's this called
the cheekbone line it's like so I was
like did I not get the manscaped and
bring it to you I got out the manscaped
the buzzer guy
handled okay
was I not like dude you're getting
wrinkly I'm dating someone he's 28 he's
way too old for me and I was like you're
getting wrinkles
ha it's dead serious I was like you need
to start using this manscape so all
these products you have no excuse and if
you're gonna finger a girl or have sex
with her you better not put bacteria
that causes UTIs you need to be taking
showers washing your hands before you
have sex with girls before you finger
them anything
manscaped is here to help
that's right 20 off plus free shipping
by going to manscape.com Whitney Santa
forgive me sometimes it's okay to be on
the naughty list because you don't want
to use the other stuff I know you got
like uh this is so good the smell of it
dude I cannot get over this smell it
smells like oh my God it smells like a
high school quarterback who's of age
when you when you are able to have I've
only ever had one orgasm where it was I
think it was hitting all three at the
same time so it was clitoral vaginal NG
spot all at the same time and I was on
top I the only way I can have like a
monster orgasm is if I'm On Top yeah
because you're able to control yeah so I
think that's probably why you had that
really good orgasm when you were sitting
on the chair and you know what else
about that I look back at that time and
I'm like how come I only I could never
do that again I was like 25 I I didn't
um what's the word I wasn't it was
someone that was like I you know like my
first kind of boyfriend when I was
younger I wasn't insecure about my body
I didn't have self-doubt yet there
wasn't a comment section yeah the world
hadn't beat you down yes and I was like
yes I was actually like inhaling and
exhaling and I didn't think he was gonna
think I was broken or weird for taking
too long I wasn't worried about wasting
his time and then I learned later like
oh I started being attracted to these
guys that you know I had to audition for
their approval I I was insecure in the
relationship so I I thought I had to
just fake an orgasm and I didn't think I
could like look ugly or look I wanted it
to just look effortless for their ego
yeah
I didn't want them to take it personally
that I couldn't come really fast do you
think you had that pressure that also
came from porn like watching the way
women have orgasms in porn because I
think that hooked me up for a while
because it's like you watch these women
who are like beautiful and Flawless and
like all the right light and like you
know all the right tone and it's like
you know everything is like you know
Flawless in porn and and the way because
it's edited you don't see all like the
weird like awkward movements in between
you don't you don't watch them switching
positions and it's weird like it's sex
is Clumsy like like very awkward we're
both like giraffe women too like we're
very limited like going from position to
position with us is like sorry I might
like fucking elbow you in the eyes stop
music to me number one sexing is music
okay what kind of music do you like okay
so I've got
can I tell you it took me a long time to
realize like how sensitive I am to music
like have you noticed when you hang out
with me music is very really always it's
very rarely playing when I'm alone but
when people are over I always have you
very specifically you were so weird when
I was organized in the closet you were
like do you want me to turn music on and
I was like no I'm fine you're like are
you sure and I was like I don't I
literally need silence right now like
even if you turned it on I wouldn't even
hear it and the way I am with music is
the way and with any kind of drugs like
everyone thinks that you know like you
would assume with my personality I'm on
drugs but like I'm very specific about
saving things so that they're as
effective as possible when I use them so
I'm like I'm not gonna do the ketamine
therapy the drip uh heroin I'm saving it
for when my dog said because I want it
to work really well I need this all the
time by the way this is that this is the
whole thing this isn't a bit this is
what she says in real life and by the
way I think that knowing you and knowing
your relation to your dogs please for
the love of God
because I don't know what I'm gonna do I
have I'm such a perfectionist too and
I'm like it's like um you know people
like go Eating Disorders a lot of times
go hand in hand with uh drug use and
alcohol abuse but it's hard to delineate
what's what because a lot of times you
know people that drink a lot they don't
eat because they want the alcohol to hit
as hard as possible you know so then
when they start getting sober it's like
oh is that really an eating disorder or
do I really just want this to be as
potent as possible so I'm like that with
music too where I'll deprive myself of
it so when it does when I do hear it's
that much better it's so intense you
know and so um for me sex wise like I do
this is embarrassing this is so
embarrassing but sex is embarrassing I
do have to kind of pretend I'm in a
music video because I do is that why you
like lingerie do people know that you
like lingerie by the way it's weird I I
used to really like it and now I kind of
um
I don't know I went through a big
lingerie phase oh I know I I organized
your closet it is the amount of the
amount of lingerie honestly like that is
the one thing I've wanted to do is take
your lingerie and auction it off and
like raise money for a cause but I
wanted to do this and Whitney was like
we're not raising money for our cause I
have money let me just give money to the
cause what is this like performance of
raising money like and that's one thing
that you always say about like if I'm
ever like hey so there's this cause like
can we do this and you're like I have
money let me just give my money to help
people like I don't think we need to go
through this whole song and dance and I
that's one that is how much do I need to
donate so we don't have to do this so we
don't have to do this
donate so I don't have to have 19
000 emails from a bunch of Rich ass moms
in Brentwood raising money like write
the check when when we went to the when
you won the Rodney Dangerfield award
when you got that and they were doing an
auction afterwards
and you just bought a visit to Jay
Leno's garage for ten thousand dollars
because I think you were just like all
right let's move it along here okay
let's just fucking raise the money and
everybody kept like bidding more and
you're like more money how much money do
I have to put down to get everybody to
just shut the fuck up and like just
spend the most money you possibly can
because everyone here has the most money
you possibly can and let's just raise
money and go home like this is such a
stupid performance and then what did you
drop like ten thousand dollars to go to
Jail's garage who's your friend he's
also my friend you could just be like
hey
um burned down two weeks well yeah
that's the thing so Jay Leno's he burnt
it down just so you didn't have to come
over
he's like he's like wait what Whitney is
gonna cash in on that I can't have her
here as if spending that amount of money
to tour Jay Leto's garage wasn't dumb
enough it's also not there anymore
that's wait I don't know it didn't burn
down he was fixing one of his cars and
it exploded in his case yeah so he's
okay he does have some Burns um I can't
help but write some jokes about it you
know for the Bert Chrysler roast which
we're shooting soon Trevor Wallace is
hosting and I wrote a joke that was like
um you know I really wanted to host the
Jay Lotto Rose but he already did that
on himself
um but no that was like kind of uh for
me I think my friends that are really
famous Comics you know I I know I really
try to um not treat them like famous
comics and my uncle Mark uh who I love
more than anything I know he would love
to tour Jake at Leto's garage but Leno
let me tour it with my dad once and so
but it's my nightmare to ask Jay for
another favor so it's like I'd rather
just buy this for my uncle to give him a
tour yeah so and then raise money for a
Cause what I would pay to not have to
ask Jay
and then you know now he's in the ER so
thank God I don't have to
um well you're gonna have to do that at
some point and go there with your um by
the way your Uncle Mark was literally
the greatest man alive okay wait so
what's the music that you play during
school well I have some go-to's I Kings
of Leon you can never really failure
he says you it's you can't help but
laugh a little with sex on fire comes on
but it is so good yeah
um 1975 is pretty good okay uh blood
orange is always great Frank Ocean
always great that or a job because
here's the thing I am a little bit
insecure sexually so if I feel like I
know the music really well what do you
want to hear about sexually
I guess I'm
um insecure about just I guess how good
I am at it or what I I'm I like to know
what's gonna happen before it happens
but sexually and you're such a control
freak I know but sexually I want someone
who's gonna totally Alpha me so it's the
only time where I truly don't know
what's gonna happen next and I don't
want to but I always in every other part
of my life I'm so I guess I just get
anxious do you know what you like
sexually
I am not a I like this and I like you to
flip me like this with everyone it's
kind of different because I want them to
do what they want to do do you know I
don't want them to listen to me so the
thing you like about sex is the power
Dynamic ultimately there's that I think
here's what I I can tell you what I
don't like okay I definitely don't like
I was talking about this to um someone
the other day I don't like it when
you're hooking up with something for the
first time and they go into the
autopilot of what worked with the last
girl yes it's such a turn off to me it's
such a I'm like and in my last Bachelor
I made fun of guys that ask permission
for stuff this is like a joke but I
definitely like it when a guy is like
present and he's like what about this
dude he's checking in in a way that's
like I'm not just gonna fuck you the way
I fucked my ex yeah and I know that
every pussy is different and every
woman's brain is different like what
works for you so you like watching them
figure out or watching them go like try
to uh like conquer this new thing yeah
and be like into it instead of
demoralized of like I don't know how to
make you come I don't know how to make I
like the idea like that they're into the
challenge of like I'm starting from
scratch I I can fuck you any way you
want but like what do you Whitney just
really loves an entry-level employee
she just really loves a guy who's on day
one of his job and you just want to
watch him struggle in the mail room you
know where he's like oh Which slot do I
put it in okay this guy's on this floor
this guy's on this one I don't want to
lose this job I'm working as hard as I
can but here's what I can I do not it is
not a turn on to me when you're hooking
up with a guy and he just like pinches
one nipple and like puts his finger
right in here and then like moves your
head but sucks at that and you're just
like this would I I know exactly what
made your ex come great I know I now I
can fuck her and make her come I now
know her very well yeah super intimately
but like I don't like it when it's just
a guy will treat every woman as like the
same woman a guy that knows like I know
your pussy is totally different than
anyone else's okay so I think I think
pussies have more variation than than
penises do for sure yeah um do you are
there things when it comes to like sex
that you're like oh this is this is
something I'm fucking good at like let
me do this coach put me in like are you
like very very it's it's it's
unfortunate because I am retired but I'm
very good at blow jobs yeah I'm horrible
at hand jobs no one's going
by the way I
friend one of my first boyfriends when I
moved to LA he used to like it when I
would give him a hand job with baby
powder
and I've I I have never met another guy
like this but I would like that is
appropriate in Geisha culture first of
all
I would cover his dick in baby powder
and I would give him like a baby powder
hand job you know what baby powder is
kind of cold when it hits though the
talc oh yes it is sometimes it's smooth
it gets smooth actually it's smooth it's
very smooth so he would like it was like
a super silky smooth hand job but also
baby powder causes cancer
um so I mean I don't know if he's still
alive I'm sure he's still alive but um
um uh by the way baby powdering balls by
by all means baby powder oh yeah great
great great but wait why are you saying
yeah um I'm great at blow jobs hand jobs
I've never I'm really good mine I am
Reese this is very recent that I have
entered into the Shameless uh oil uh
body oil with a pump on the side of the
bed Lube standing by phase because I
always thought that lube was like you're
basically like admitting I can't get wet
or you're not hot to me like I just go
for it right away because it takes off
the like am I wet enough am I not gonna
get wet enough and then that sort of
like brain paralysis also that the
wetness that you the artificial wetness
like it gets real wetness 100. like it
just yeah get that out of the way that's
totally fine and but oil like oil by the
bed pump yeah like uh hand job with oil
firm minute I'll totally do but I have a
lot of rings and I don't like taking
them off yeah I don't need you to get
tetanus from my heart but but there is
there are some guys who do like that
that it's the pain as pleasure kind of
thing but you want to know you don't
want it to be like you're not but I mean
just as long as it's not the stabby
portion right but like just that extra
ribbing of the right I bet there are
guys who like that but why why have you
retired from giving blowjobs because to
me but it's weird blowjobs are always
have always been way more intimate to me
I I I think blow jobs are way more
intimate than I'll have sex I'll have
sex before I'll yep I'll have sex before
I'll give a blowjob and do you think do
you
what do you think what do you think is
easier to make a guy come from sex or a
blowjob
like if I was like if I was like Winnie
you get in that fucking game you better
make this guy come as fast as you
fucking can which which move are you
gonna pull
I'm your stuff I would like to phone a
friend yeah I'm gonna put a friend on
this one Alex I oh I mean I guess I
I might be a little rusty I think that I
think I know exactly what to do in a
blowjob it's less about the the action
of it and more about the being able to
know how to gag really well yeah and uh
gag really hard and then sorry guys I
mean this is this is what this episode
yeah this is Alex Cooper Number One
podcast okay we're doing this now yeah
the people want to hear about it let's I
mean let's do this yeah so gagging on it
and then pulling up and letting the spit
like like stringy space spit spit spit
spit down on it you gotta nail it though
you can't miss it you know because then
I'll get to more lives yeah yeah and
then you'll be like God what am I you
gotta get it and then you just have to
fucking you know Milk The Cow and
usually that'll do it and now that I
have like fake tits now I know how to
just make them jiggle and then I'll do
it kind of kind of between my tits okay
a little bit all right I like I like all
this so you've been you've retired from
doing that and then also I'm sorry but I
have a spit my mouth type of edge
spit him oh I'm gonna spit my mind
I know we're close if I know we're close
and I've got to be somewhere I got a
zoom call in 20. yeah yeah it's a bit of
my face bit of my mouth spit in my mouth
and then I'll let it come up yeah
dribble just just a disgusting mess but
the by the way the someone's spitting in
your face is the ultimate you are the
alpha so I think that's why you like it
if a guy spits in your face that is him
that is an ultimate he's alphaing you
that's like I love it yeah I'm very into
it love it love it so if you say it yeah
I spit in my mouth I'm not gonna tell
you to do it you just fucking yeah yeah
yeah I need a little heads up just don't
do it so early yeah yeah do it at a time
where we're in the home stretch yeah so
that I don't have to like like
um like sometimes I'll spit in your face
and it'll just get a little yolk like
here and then you have to like kind of
then I'm like all pirate eye I'm all and
now I'm kind of like trying to pretend
it's not in my eye and then I have to
sort of casually like as we turn around
this and then I'm like we're back then
like it's just don't make either nail it
or hold till right before the Finish
Line if if a guy is coming on your face
how are you about with coming on the
face you know what there's one by the
way one of the questions somebody asked
is as long as you're fine with missing
and me laughing at you yes okay so
that's the thing do you think it's funny
if a guy because it's like when it comes
to coming guys some guys are Shooters
some guys are dribblers yeah um a little
for me it just looks like like a little
baby drool
um uh and you know it's like for the
guys who are dribblers I feel bad for
them they never get to do like a good
money shot it's just that like Jackson
pollocking it on your face isn't that
more though that if they've jerked off
recently or they haven't like practiced
holding it up so that it'll have more
torque some guy there's there's actually
there's a it's the pressure of it I
think is called I think if you jerk off
too much I think it's called turgor
pressure
um if if Pat could you look that up okay
sorry trigger pressure but also like
yeah you if you know that you're a
dribbler maybe maybe don't pull the
money shot like you don't want your dick
to just be like like gently weeping yeah
gently again just crying it's just him
doing like an egg drop on your face like
oh it's a really it's a really I
actually have a whole act out in in my
stand-up about like a dude trying to
come on you when he's a drippy guy yeah
it's it's anticlimactic and then you
just have to pretend you don't see sugar
pressure is the force uh
uh uh pressure and fluid measured at a
certain point within itself when at
equilibrium generally trigger pressure
is caused by the F
the osmotic flow of water that occurs in
Plants fungi and bacteria the phenomena
is observed in proto okay check
huberman.com for this I don't know but
this is basically uh you just uh turgid
well the word turgid is when something
is moving slowly uh trigger pressure
wait uh will you search trigger pressure
and penis but this is I was gonna say
this is just in general not just for the
trigger pressure and penis
interesting
but you can practice you can build it up
like I know a guy like he jerks off
jerks off gets to it holds it jerks off
jerks off yeah I know exactly you're
talking about yeah um yeah there is
there is definitely
um anyways there's a certain kind of
pressure I mean look at that
um there is a certain kind of pressure
that causes it some guys just don't get
distance some guys are just never gonna
be big Shooters yeah yeah yeah some guys
are just dripping know yourself but you
but you can I'm sure you can you know
train yourself to do anything but I
think a lot of times when guys watch too
much porn and they just come as quickly
as possible by the time you get to sex
like you don't have the endurance the
guy who I was just seeing would like
um like if he knew we were going to be
having sex like he wouldn't jerk off at
all like if you knew even like days out
he would like it was like and there's
this part of me that was just like he's
saving his jizz for me I was like that
is so romantic he could have gotten me
flowers and I'd been like fuck these
flowers but the fact that he like saved
himself for days at a time and then when
I like and then when he did come on me
I'd always be like it's mine it's all
mine this is my jizz this is my this is
my come thank you so much I think
there's also things you can say like I
think that when I was younger I didn't
know the value of saying the perfect
thing in bed if you want to get someone
to come or whatever it is so it's like I
think when I was younger I just thought
you have to be as loud as possible you
have the Kim Kardashian sex tape had
come out and it was like it was like you
had to just do you needed to sound like
a little an animal dying yes that's
animals struggling for like a little
tiny chipmunk yeah
and then guys are like oh is that an
animal dog
that's all they want is to just murdered
hit by a card slowly dying on the
freeway that's the sound you make to get
a man to really fucking blow up like
whimper whimper and then you know
screaming and stuff you're never I'm not
I cannot focus on it feeling good if I'm
focusing on giving the performance of a
lifetime you know but there if I'm
dating someone and like I'll they want
to have sex in the morning I'll let them
finish inside me and then if we're gonna
have sex like that night or whatever
it's always like it's like I felt your
calm all in my panties all day from this
morning
wow you know what I mean
so you do or you said you're poetic
you're you just it's just like uh I was
thinking about you all day because
you're you know you say in a way that's
not like the clam chowder crystallized
in my Hanes granny panties you know you
have to just say it in a way that is
sort of like somewhat sexy but putting
that we're comedians our job is to put
an image in someone's head and have them
yeah it is men are visual creatures as
long as you just create an image like
there is there is you if you can do that
for them because they're already I mean
you know if you're saying it while
you're in the bedroom they're already
fucking you so they're already getting a
great visual if you just add a layer to
that yes where they're like oh my God
not only am I dominating her in this
moment but I've been dominating her in
moments throughout the day yes so I've
been occupying rent free in her brain
for the day yes yes and just the idea
that like you know and the little things
like that like knowing and it made me
realize so few women kind of do it
because I think that it's I don't know
talking in bed is very awkward I'm not a
chatty Kathy in bed to be honest but
very surprising but it's very surprising
that you're not calling shots in bed by
the way the fact that you don't have
your phone on you while you're getting
by the way there is something very hot
about like
just being on your phone while a guy's
fucking I'll tell you right now so the
guy who I was just saying um he was
helping me edit a video where I'm doing
a joke about a young girl giving a
blowjob and when you're in your 20s
you're just like every girl in her 20s
thinks she's so good at sucking dick
yeah like when I was in my 20s like I
could have like a conversation with
every single one of my girlfriends and
it would just be a competition about who
sucks the best and when I was in my 20s
I was literally sucking dick as if it
was like corn on a cob yeah
know what I was doing
no clue surprising you did so well in
your career
um uh the anyway so I don't even know
what I was just saying oh that sorry
sucking dick in your 20s sucking dick in
your 20s but oh no so I was I was he was
helping me edit this clip because he was
an editor
um and he made this joke where he's like
wouldn't it be so funny if you sucked my
dick right now while I was editing a
video about you sucking dick doing a
joke about you sucking look and I was
just like challenge accepted and then I
blew him while he was doing it and then
all of a sudden he like stopped editing
because he was like enjoying it and and
like I heard my voice stop and then I
like pulled away I was like I'm gonna
need to continue hearing my voice and
doing your work if I'm gonna finish this
job okay and he was like I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry and then he like got back
to editing it and then yeah I'm now just
as I'm more comfortable in my own skin
like into that type of shit yeah but
like when I was younger I just was like
all I wanted was to like look thin and
look pretty and like you know instead of
going oh the hottest thing is to just
create a situation that we've both never
been in before a thousand percent you
know let me ask you though about
squirting so I've tried to make myself
you can make yourself so I just want to
see if I can do it myself one time I did
it in like Phoenix in a hotel room I was
like I was working on I mean it's a it's
a story it's been told many times about
a woman went to Phoenix and was like you
know what this is the place where it's
gonna happen and where you have the
least amount of hydration your body's
like I went to a desert in order to see
if I could squirt but I because I was
working on my HBO special I was dating a
guy who on like the second date was like
you know he was like astounded that I
didn't squirt after fucking me for like
30 seconds no you don't squirt he got
like really offended by it and I was
like I got really into it and I couldn't
do it during sex I don't think I've done
it during sex before but I tried to make
myself do it but just explain to me this
is where you shine this is okay so I'm a
squirter always like the all like the
first time I've had sex not the first
time it's it's progressively gotten more
and more or the older I've gotten and
now it's just all the time it is whole
it is it is to the point I've been I've
been doing a joke about it in my
stand-up where guys will find out you're
a squirter and it's like oh that's so
sexy and I'm like no I will destroy a
house okay do you want to lose a chair
because I'll you'll never get that thing
fixed your mattress coils will Rust
thrust through and through no no you
have to have like six mattress covers um
it's not like I can't just have like fun
spontaneous sex like we can't just be on
the couch watching TV and then like have
sex unless you have a fucking drop cloth
it's a full Dexter like
I need yes everything go down in the
basement yes no no like it is it is you
need to just tell them can you can you
just like have quick sex in an elevator
just real quick even if you don't come
and not squirt uh it'll it'll be
questionable okay it'll be questionable
like it's not it's not it's to the point
now where it's like first of all it's
like if you have a big dick I will
squirt period right away right like
because it'll just it's just pressure
it's like you'll just hit that spot and
it'll just happen let me ask you
something but like how much of it is
psychological and how much of it is
physiological
I mean for you personally
uh I I would say I would say a vast
majority of it is physiological I don't
there I have a lot of like because I was
with one guy recently not very recently
but fairly recently I was with one guy
who was grossed out by it and it really
fucked with my head how so how did that
um he was just like oh my God uh uh oh
what's happening and I was like is it
Woody Allen who
[Laughter]
I mean honestly the guy was a smoke show
super hot and I thought he would Bando
it and he was not into it at all and
that was we only had sex once that was a
it was it was a see I just got really
upset is just like that fucking pig most
men are really into it well because also
he might have they I think there was a
rumor going around that it was P it is
it is p it's p it's p yeah it's there's
it's not Alby but there's a vast
majority of it is p but here's the thing
like so I'm empty I could fully empty my
bladder before we have sex and I could
still squirt a fucking ocean loud and
while you're squirting or is that feel
like what a clitoral orgasm would feel
is that a technically an orgasm no it's
it is it is it's a muscle contraction
that's happening so it's the sort of
thing when you when I have an orgasm I
can squirt at the same time but I can
squirt and it's just it's it's like a
pressure release so it just feels good
um but it's not this you can squirt
while you're getting fucked and then
have an orgasm later and they're
separate things totally because that's
the other thing is that I think guys
think that when a woman's squirting
they're coming no that is not a woman
having an orgasm necessarily they can be
having an orgasm at the same time yeah I
mean guys they're like did your water
just break I'm like do you think I'm
pregnant like what yeah I'm giving I
mean yeah I had a little bit of salt at
dinner but like it's just a tad bloated
it is it is
it is unbelievable like what the human
body can do it is it's when it's
happening I'm like what in the fucking
fuck even I'm like oh my God yeah like
there is there have been times where
like I'll be like hanging off the edge
of the bed this one dude I was sleeping
with what do you mean hanging off the
edge like my my like my like butts
hanging off the edge of the bed so if a
guy's fucking me off the side of the bed
wait but you're hold on so you're bent
over the bed
so if this is the edge of the bed yeah
you're so I'm saying I'm laying on the
bed okay he has me on the bed like that
okay my lower half it's like anyhow so
he would do that and he had hardwood
floors and so I would just be like
squirting onto the floor and so then he
would be losing track oh that's so funny
he like fell in some Bambi on ice
that's
um and then he eventually just had to
put towels down so he could get grip no
he needs if someone fucks Nicole they
have to get those little toe shoes with
the grip on the bottom the Vibram toe
shoes you have to wear Tevas you can you
can use those for shredding on Trails or
fucking Nicole
um it is it's yeah it's it's a whole
thing it's a whole thing it's I mean
I've I've go to a pelvic floor therapist
now because of it because I'm just like
at one point I was like okay this is
getting weird it's getting weird and but
but dude it's just that as you get older
or just as you do it more it gets easier
to or you have less control of it or
see that's one thing I'm not so I spoke
to a therapist a pelvic floor therapist
about it and she's like there's just no
money in research for this yeah yeah
like no one's putting their money into
figuring this I think there are a couple
scientists out there who would love to
absolutely take time I'm going to send
you a link I found there was a
scientific study had done about it and
there's a video for it you just can't be
this funny you just can't be the
scientist that's like my life's work my
life finding out no one cares that much
about women unfortunately like if you
look at all the investing in different
things for humans it's a lot of it's for
men when it comes to sexuality honestly
in terms of Empirical research but like
no one ever thinks to want to talk I'm
sure male porn stars or porn stars
probably know the most thousand percent
yeah a thousand percent the people I
talk to about squirting the most are my
friends who are in porn yeah like it's
it's just something like also but
there's girls in porn who are like don't
squirt and then there's girls in porn
who are like if you've seen have you
have you watched like a lot of squirting
porn it is
unbelievable the trajectory Factory that
some of these girls can get it's big
yeah it's like the Bellagio fountain
it's like like when an elephant gets
water and it's a little and it's like I
don't know if that's what I'd want to do
like I don't know that which that would
stress me out maybe if it was his house
yeah if see I mean that's the whole
thing like whose house are we fucking at
I really you know one of my main things
is coasters I don't let it go I cannot I
can't have a water stain as as my my
uncle uh used to say you have no respect
for wood
water on the floor water destroys wood I
mean is a good point I mean it really is
a good point the only thing that matters
more to me than orgasms are my hardwood
floors I mean you have stunning hardwood
floors by the way these are like
industrial strength Hardwoods yeah these
are actually fine but yeah okay so let's
dig in I'm going to get a little bit
granular we're going to keep talking
about squirting don't uh Panic
um so by the way if someone has
questions about squirting For Me Yeah by
all means It's tricky because I think
it's a case-by-case thing but I and
maybe I'm just I'm like pushing this
narrative but I think a lot of it is
also mental as you get older as a woman
get more comfortable in your skin you're
more comfortable in sex like I find in
general like and also the partner you
choose as I get you know uh more and
more recovery and more and more
self-esteem I've stopped only wanting to
date guys that I think I will slip
through the cracks at any moment or I
could lose at any moment I'm working so
hard to get them to love me and so when
I have sex with them I'm just bone dry
because I'm full of fear and panic and
then when I date guys that made me feel
good about myself or I don't feel like I
have to chase or impress I feel like I'm
always so really quick I know we were
going to go into the questions but I'm
just wondering because this is something
I've been struggling with recently like
a lot of the power I've felt I've had in
my life is my sexual power over men like
I I one of the biggest sources of
self-esteem for me throughout my life
has been my my sexual abilities blowjobs
having sex just being a sexual person
like I'm it is something I know I'm good
at like I thrive at that
have you ever felt like you were with
someone and that was gonna you were like
oh I'm gonna fucking rock their world
they're gonna love me after I fuck them
yes but I think I had a little bit of
the opposite I was like my only Power is
sex so I'm gonna withhold it oh
interesting that was a big one because
it's sort of like you know and I also
yeah I don't know I I had sexual abuse
as again I was very weird about that
like I think for my 20s early 30s I if I
was gonna hook up with someone it'd be
like a six monthly time yeah like they
really had to like earn it yeah I
remember when you came to visit Michigan
you hooked up with one of our friends in
a bathroom I don't remember I do kind of
remember that actually because because I
think it was at a time where I was
putting uh chicken cutlets in my
Brawlers and I remember have leaving
them there because I had to take them
out real quick and I put them in some
drawer and I'm like what do I ask for
them back all I know is that guy I can't
remember his name but he when you were
on punked and I went home to Michigan I
remember he saw me and he's like the
girl I hooked up with in the bathroom
it's on punked I was like this is
literally the only famous thing you will
ever do in your life is fuck a girl who
is unpunked or whatever you did um I
think so with I think that I was like so
manipulative with sex for so long it
wasn't about me enjoying it it was about
me trying to like control someone or
keep someone or make sure I didn't get
abandoned or try to seek love I had such
a like Twisted relationship with sex for
a long time but yes I think I kind of
knew and that was a lot of the lingerie
stuff it's like I might not have be the
best at sex I might not be the prettiest
I might not be God damn it am I gonna
look good but when I get there yes but I
like you know I look like um a chicken a
chicken cordon bleu wrapped in that you
know what I mean a delicious I'm gonna
put the most effort in and I'm gonna be
so memorable that you know every girl
after me is gonna you know it's just not
gonna by the way my favorite part about
going going through Whitney's lingerie
was like there would be a couple of them
where I just like there was a jizz stain
on that man I was like the fact that
Whitney was just like when she was done
having sex she was like I need to hide
this and just put it back into the
drawer well it's also like I don't
really need to know how to clean laundry
the idea how do you how to tell you
hold hand wash cold I think lingerie
it's at its best when it's oh kind of a
one and done Amazon 22 yeah let it rip
it off because I think a big move I did
in my 20s was pantyhose and you ripped
the panties yeah so you rip around your
you know the crevices the pantyhose mind
blown trash it's you know done I I
ruined this thing yeah I I ruined this
to get to you this primordial thing
we're in such a rush we don't have time
to take this off whatever and so I think
that nothing is less sexy than being an
expensive lingerie
[Laughter]
so when I'm stressing out about
expensive lingerie getting ruined that's
not fun but then the reason there's
probably gum stains on them because I
was like
I think I would get in a fight with
somebody like why do you want to take
this off right away yeah you know but
I'm like this is precious don't ruin it
and he's like well how do I and then so
they would come on it or something it
would come on exactly and then I and
then it somehow it would just make it
right back into the drawer um and then I
was going through the drawer of lingerie
and I was like there is a this is this
is this is the DNA box this is what this
is there's yeah it's just in case this
is evidence yes things yeah I just want
to be able to frame all the men yeah
that have fucked me at any point if you
fucked Whitney just know that your head
is on The Chopping Block I still have
your DNA in my uh bedside drawer but
also yeah how do you know we weren't
just eating lobster bisque I mean oh
what type of ejaculate exit do most
women prefer
oh the word we were just talking about
that shooting it out or dripping out
literally what part of your body do you
like if a guy's gonna come on you or do
you want them to come on you I like a I
like it I like a stomach I like a
stomach because then my boobs I can hold
them up in a way that I know looks cute
yes you know I like on the stomach and
then you take a picture at the end and
send it to him a couple days later on
something uh I like at the promise on
the boobs like I think it gets confusing
because you have to if you're gonna come
on tits you have to start a little lower
for it to hit and I think a lot of times
guys go to come in your tits and they
just hit your neck yeah yeah and it just
gets like awesome yeah then it just
looks like you have a chin bugger yeah
and I have the keratin hair bonds now I
don't want come up and you know yeah I
think stomach is like a clear Target
it's hard to miss you get your photo
after easy cleanup
on butt is sometimes good I'm I'm a huge
butt person yeah I'm like I'm a butt
like I have this one picture that a guy
a guy came on my butt and it was just
like dripping down and it was like when
I was like I don't know 30 and my butt
was like the hardest and highest it's
ever been wild yeah no but like when I
was 30 my ass was like Unstoppable
anyway so it's just like it was just
like jizz just like dripping down my
giant ass cheek and I was just like this
and I have it it's in black and white
it's stunning oh um and it's like on my
back a little bit too it's just it's
Artful um but yeah where do you stand on
sending photos sexual photos to people
that were taken with someone out like I
didn't do that I wouldn't yeah what are
you gonna do with that phone you know no
I mean that's oh that's just for me yeah
yeah that's just for me that's just for
me when I was like look at my ass look
at what it was yeah it had a load all
over it how do you successfully deep
throat without having to gag or bite
swallow that is how you do it if you
really want to if you really want to
deep throat a dick like you had to
really get it down there you have to get
it to the back of your throat and then
swallow to bring it even further down
but how I gag when I brush my teeth I
mean you just have to relax ultimately
that's what the swallowing does you just
have to relax so this is what you meant
on This Time by saying when you need to
do nothing yeah do not by that I just
fucking relax I love it by the way when
I was over here once I was like Whitney
I was like you need to just do nothing
just shit with the door hope and
Whitney's like how much Ayahuasca did
you do
that you think shitting with the door
opens the solution to my problem so she
literally goes she's like I'm doing
eyebrows here this weekend I'm like oh
godspeed work through the dad stuff she
comes back she's like you need a shit
with the door open make full eye contact
with me as you're shitting I'm like like
I don't know was that Ayahuasca I feel
like that was like ketamine did you have
did you have Dawn liquid soap did they
mix it what about pea fetishes I guess
squirting technically Falls in that cat
I dated a guy who had a pink fetish I
would catch on him he would he would pee
on me like when we were in the shower he
would always pee on me it wasn't like
every guy does that I know but it's like
he like really did it was like really
his thing but you were on because I've
told the story before on the podcast but
one time a guy uh I was like yeah pee on
me were like laugh like like I was like
let's do it at some point when we're in
a shower that's funny you know and uh we
were in like Hong Kong or something and
we went in the shower and he did it and
I would like put my you know I was like
the water was already coming down but
he's I couldn't stop laughing
there are a lot of fetishes to me that
are just very funny and I think peeing
is certainly one of them but you so you
were able to keep a straight face no not
at all I was dying I was dying the whole
time there's I am never listen I am I am
down to get into some dirty sex shit but
I'm never I'm never a guy's Never Gonna
Be peeing on me and I'm gonna be like oh
yeah yeah
give me that
Uno
I want to be your body oh someone's in
ketosis like it's so like ew like stop
but I think it's more the intent to go
there and I think there's something hot
I've just started thinking it's fun to
like crack up during sex oh
sex is the best you know I you know it's
it sounds to me like you've had Shame
about sex in your lifetime so I think
the fact that you're like able to like
laugh during sex is
such progress for you because you're
really like letting go like if you can
laugh during sex so fun in a way that's
not like embarrassed sex it's just
you're just laughing at like sex is a
fucking ridiculous but it is absolutely
insane it's so silly and also uh there's
an this is a very new thing
unrelenting eye contact so this is
something recent that I think is kind of
hot and I sort of stumbled upon it
um when I had a knee injury which is
like just lying there and doing
absolutely nothing like full Ragdoll but
on purpose and just like staring into
the distance staring off and not into
their eyes I think staring into the eyes
is like a new one but this was when I
was working on the the sex robot thing
and I was doing all this research for
that special about it and I started
watching oh my God I can't believe I'm
admitting this I started just for
research purposes going on PornHub and
looking at sex robot porn now I'm gonna
have I've never looked at it and I there
was something really hot about it
because
it's kind of just like a guy jerking off
and you're not distracted by the girls
like bruises or tattoo that says breathe
where you're like or the ingrown hair I
can't if a girl has an ingrown hair I
can't is it an ingrown you gotta go I'm
like and if it's if it's if it's really
big I'm just like did you want to
squeeze it there's yeah there's when you
see that yeah yeah or shave with the
grain you can't go against the grain but
yeah it kills me so maybe I was just
able to focus on the hotness of someone
wanting to come without like thinking
about whether what the girl was doing
was true or not like if I see an acrylic
nails that's what one thing Whitney
likes it's authenticity in her porn she
wants to watch people really just be in
an authentication we're distracted I get
distracted by like you know is she okay
it's like why are you in a yoga ball
like there's just so much to process now
is that in the W Hotel lobby like I
don't know what's happening and then um
so there was something hot about that to
me and then I was dating this guy who
was kind of perverse and
um I can't explain it like he was he was
very um obsessive and intense and it
sexually and it made me uh feel too much
pressure to be like Intense or something
so I kind of just like one night to just
play with a different
um what's the word tone I just kind of
like and I was kind of mad at him too
and I was sort of trying to punish him a
little bit and this is I was more
immature at the time but it ended up
being hot I just like stared at him and
just laid there and like did absolutely
nothing
that's kind of hot and it was actually
really hot that's really super fucking
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm into that and it
was it was like just just staring like
Dead Eye kind of I don't know there was
something really hot about it not for
all the time there is eye contact really
is like oh God like if you're like about
to come really hard if you're with
someone you really love yeah yeah and
you're about to come and you guys lock
eyes really hard it's like because the
best is I mean this is probably I mean
everyone knows this the being like can I
come yeah like if you oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh so hot so hot like and if a
guy says no I will marry you yeah the
power dynamics of sex that's really what
I'm in it for is like I I want it's it's
a power play Everything number one turn
off for you in bed from a man
like something where you're just like ah
bummer I think
I think going for the asshole too fat I
don't like when a guy's fucking you and
then is trying to like rub on your clit
and put the finger on that and it's just
like stop they're just like playing
Simon yeah remember that gate or
whack-a-mole yeah like I don't it's just
stressful to me yeah to have to process
that much stimulation like just do one
thing well and then we'll build up to
you yeah that to me it's like when you
start trying to like occupy all the
holes it's just like we've been dating
for a week like relax yeah yeah but it's
it's sort of like
um
if a guy's squeamish like I don't want
to feel like like if a guy like I
remember I dated a guy who like fingered
me and then I watched him just like wipe
his hand on the sheet
and I'm just like I'm like are you like
grossed out by my pussy like why are you
here yeah yeah like like sex to me if if
I don't leave sex being like I'm
disgusting right now and I need a shower
then we never had sex like sex to me is
gross like at its best it is a
disgusting act that we do together and
it's hilarious yeah it should smell like
a 7-Eleven in there she's smelling what
7-Elevens are you going to I mean I know
you live in Nevada 912.
um uh wait what's uh Am Pm um anyway so
yeah that's a bummer I think one of the
biggest turn-offs is a guy that's not
into having sex on your period oh yeah
no no no get your Red Wings show up
because also I'm not big on having guys
go down on me I don't know why maybe I'm
I'm not I don't need it I don't need it
I don't totally know maybe it's because
it's kind of a beta thing yeah like I'd
prefer just fingering and you're just
hand around my neck and you're looking
at whatever that I can do but like it
feels like too much pressure I kind of
I'm not sure if it's for him or for me
I'm just not that into it yeah you know
maybe I just haven't had the right
person do it I don't know but when
you're like on your period and guys like
that's the time he's gonna go down it's
just even if that's not your thing for a
guy to just go like this is how
hot I think you are this is how how bad
I want you yeah I want to taste you at
every time of the month or like this is
how much of a fucking sick motherfucker
I am do you know what I'm saying because
also most period blood is like black
slush
I'm sorry when I when I was on birth
control it was literal black sludge yeah
yeah so it's like to me it just it's
it's going like it's his way of going
I'm not gonna let you be embarrassed
about this yeah I'm not gonna let you
feel shame I also love that there are
some guys who are like this is when you
are the most female you can be yeah is
when you're having your period you can
honestly and when you're on your period
that's when it feels the best because
you're more sensitive to it everything's
just better when you're on your period
like period sex to me all of the stuff
that goes with it yeah like put some
fucking put eight thousand towels down
it's gonna get messy do it in the shower
if you have to but definitely fuck on
your period but as for the love at this
podcast Pat blood is not
Lube blood is not Lube
if you have not taken anything from this
podcast we've said it a couple times
blood is not Loops a lot of times guys
go like oh it's gonna feel so good
you're it's like no but blood gets
sticky it dries it does you still need
real Lube you still need real Lube but
like I can come so much harder when I'm
on my period me too so much me too the
only time I ever masturbate is when I'm
on my period because that's when I'm
like my favorite thing to do yeah it's
incredible yeah it's like oh Jesus this
is going to be an absolute mess but yeah
I'm here for it and if you want to have
sex with a girl on your period get like
who is it or no I guess it was DJ Khaled
that just doesn't go down on girls at
all everybody
um what was I gonna say oh Rich Voss uh
uh husband of Bonnie McFarland hilarious
comedians he had one of my favorite
jokes ever it's like 20 years ago I saw
him at the cellar in New York and uh and
he goes uh I don't mind having sex with
a girl on her period I just pretend I'm
killing her
I mean listen that's what you guys want
to do whatever so you have to check us
on our period it'll fulfill your dream
of murdering us
um let's see how do I know how to
instruct a guy on how to make me come
I'm 20 he's 19. okay well do you know
how to make yourself come play Call of
Duty uh
uh she probably knows how to make
herself come I guess but yeah I mean I
guess that's the thing is like I think
guys are very confused about whether
they're supposed to make you them you
come with their dicks or whether
like because okay so if a guy is having
sex with you can he make you come
clitorally by by if you guys are close
enough it can be rubbing your clit but
that's not the same as an inside one and
I think that's when girls get confused
so like wait a second I started to feel
like I was about to calm yeah but it's
not from the dick in your vagina it
could be his like up lower pelvis
rubbing against your clit so it's all
angles it's all insertion it's it first
of all it's whatever works
I mean for sure by the way my credit
score is like so high that like I have
sometimes I'll just like say it while
I'm having sex I'll just be like a20 and
he's like that's not what time it is I'm
like that's how much credit I have
um uh I think like communication like
you just need to learn how to talk to
the person figure out what it is that
makes you come and then tell them and
it's not that complicated and I think it
also took me a long time to realize it's
not the yes you know being at the right
angle going at a certain speed whatever
but also breathing and being comfortable
with the person because if you're like
I'm not it's not working I must be I
have to get this done quickly or he's
going to think I'm weird or like I'm
gonna look ugly when I do come it's
really like it's it's it took me so long
to realize like and I the hottest thing
a guy can say I think if you really want
to cheat is while you're having sex with
a girl and trying to get her to come
tell her to breathe yeah like make her
breathe breathing breathing is by the
way the most important thing in in all
of it like you've got to get oxygen but
at this and sometimes you know a little
oxygen deprivation goes oh that's true
too but but definitely breathe
definitely like just know this
if you're fucking the right guy
there is nothing you can do that we'll
be discussing to him as long as you're
coming on his dick like just know that
the end goal is you coming and that is
going to be the greatest thing ever for
him yes every man wants to come but also
no this also took a long time because I
would be like oh God he thinks I'm a
weirdo because he's not making me come
and like I'm not coming fast enough and
he's going to think and it's like no no
he's going how come I'm not making her
come I'm not good enough she's worried
about making you come because his
manliness will be if you're fucking a
real man all he cares about is making
you come however fucking long that takes
he is in it to fucking win it biggest
red flag having sex with a guy and then
afterwards he's like so did you come
yeah what run don't walk run Sprint get
the fuck out of there huh like that you
get styled like I have to sometimes go
like hey I don't want to con like I just
want you to come yeah sex feels sex
feels so good to me even when I don't
have an orgasm there are times I'm just
not in the mind space yeah I'm just not
there I just you know but just
communicating that because I also think
the vagueness of guys never know am I
supposed to make you come every time
time did I make you like you also just
have to go like I just want you to come
yeah just come right now or say listen
I'm just not gonna come right now and
that's fine just be like I don't know
I'm in a weird headspace I'm just like
not I don't know why or don't you don't
even say that just go like I want you to
I just want you to use you don't need to
say that while you're having sex you
could just be like no no then you just
come but like you can even say later
like listen like I don't know why I just
like maybe I was in my head I don't know
but no I can't have comments every time
you have sex I like to hold it but it
still feels so good to me anyway it's
like a massage I look at sex it's like a
massage inside your pussy it feels great
no matter what just say and if sex with
a guy doesn't feel good when you're not
only having one of those orgasms yeah
that's not necessarily good either no
because I think it's sometimes the
hottest when I'm just like
watching him what okay wait wait wait I
just thought of something I just thought
of something I was wondering if you get
excited about it do you ever like write
right before you have sex with someone
for the first time and they have like a
really good dick and you're like you're
like oh that's gonna feel so good
and you're like right before he puts it
inside you and you're just like hold
your breath for a second you're like and
then he puts it in and you're like yeah
honey love Honey Love
honey love hey girl so honey loves this
is I'm holding up like they're basically
um
it's I don't want to say girdle because
that's an ugly word but this is like
shapewear that just snatches you dude
snatches you handles it I don't want to
say if you're pregnant in Texas buy one
of these but
that's how tight that's how much it
holds in your insides you know it's the
Honey Love bras I've been wearing them
constantly my deal is I cannot do
underwire and I don't like bras that
flatten but I need it to be like and you
ever need to be like snatched what is it
taught whatever
so cute so elegant it's very hard to
find bras that don't have lines under
the shirt that don't look like
um bandages from the ER like they're
like cute bralettes
that under a t-shirt like a silk shirt
or anything there's no lines that's the
thing about bras is you see them under a
shirt like why am I looking at the lines
of your bra you weirdo like good love
honey love treat yourself the best
shapewear on the market save 20 off at
honeylove.com with the code good for you
use code good for you at honeylove.com
feel and look as sexy as possible this
holiday with honey love shapewear ladies
you deserve it stop putting garbage made
by children and factories on your body
honey love what you put on your body
psychically matters
you're wearing it all day
I'm really
into like it's not about the product
it's also I want to know who made the
product and I want to know how it was
made I want to know where my money is
going am I paying for like children to
work in factories and make some garbage
or am I like you know what I mean you
deserve it nothing makes your tits
perkier than not having children make
the device that makes your tits perkier
so
I am a garbage person
I'm a piece of actual trash uh
unfortunately I don't fit in the loamy
I've tried
that's where I belong so I'm obsessed
with this so my big thing is normally
what I do is I fruit vegetables eat them
I normally throw all the compost the
trash out in the field so that either
can you know be reintegrated into the
Earth or the deer and the wild animals
have something to snack on because I
feel bad just throwing away fresh
nutrients like I just don't throw away
vines or you know but loamy
it's like a it's incredible if you want
to make a positive environmental impact
or just make clean up after dinner much
easier loamy is perfect for you head to
loamy.com Whitney and use the promo code
Whitney
promo code Whitney to get 50 off your
loamy 50 off when you had to loan me
sorry I just had such a good idea I
should give this for Christmas gifts
this is a great Christmas gift it is
like this to give to people is like
fucking great sorry use the promo code
to get Whitney to get 50 off your loamy
that's fifty dollars off when you head
to loan me lomi.com Whitney and use
promo code Whitney at checkout food
waste is gross yuck loamy is your
solution with the holidays just around
the corner loamy will make the perfect
gift for someone on your shopping list
loamy's all around
loamies for the homies
that is by the way me every single time
no you will never see someone more
excited to have sex than me I get so
excited you really do oh I love it so
much it's my absolute favorite thing I
get so excited do you ever have shame or
you is what is this I mean I maybe I'm
not the mom who's a nudist just human
bodies are just human bodies are just
beautiful and they are what they are um
there's a nudist like was she a nudist
when you were born too because
apparently a lot of our shame around our
bodies Our vaginas our butts all that
kind of stuff comes from what parents
don't even know that they're doing it
when they change diapers as a baby you
know they I mean I had my mom literally
popped me out and two weeks later was
back to work when there's uh when
there's a dirty diaper uh parents go ah
yeah you know just sort of like even if
it's like fun and games I'm like oh God
poopy diaper yeah and then the baby is
even seeing Oh there's something maybe
that's why first children are so fucked
up oh the shoulder fucked up because by
the time you get to the second kid maybe
that's why all second children or
younger kids or the slutty kids yeah and
they're also probably molested by the
older one yeah
let's be honest
so it's not the fact that your parents
were changing your diapers and making
fun of you for having a shitty diaper
it's that your sibling molested you I
mean look that's a I didn't know that
much about that because I'm looking into
like adoption and stuff like that and I
was learning about like the amount of um
sexual abuse there is in like the foster
care system
um you know but then again incest porn
is number one so last week I did I was
my period was late and I was like oh no
I'm fucking pregnant one of the thoughts
I had in my head honest to God I thought
I was like I could always just give the
kid to Whitney yeah actually yeah oh
that would be perfect I was like Whitney
would take this kid because she knows it
would be it would be the child of a
comedian oh my god
um and it would be perfect because like
I can't I can't afford a baby but like
Whitney could have the baby and then I
could just be like the mom on the side
occasionally as long as the father
wasn't a comedian I'd be fine yeah fine
he was not a comedian oh I love that
actually yeah you know because I have
all these eggs on ice and a lot of my
friends that are like don't have eggs
I'm like I don't know if this is
narcissistic but you can have some of
mine if you want I don't blame you for
not not wanting my DNA but by the way if
I if I ever get to the point where I do
want a kid and I've run out of eggs can
I have an egg yes please oh my God this
has just made me so happy I feel like
give them to my girlfriends and my gay
friends oh my God Whitney yeah oh my God
it's just the best you know every time I
come over you're like take whatever you
want and now I can just take an egg I
can't you need to move the frozen eggs
here well one of them had Down syndrome
we got rid of it okay so you should be
good for the most part oh why does the
other person always talk come on I'm
concentrating here so some people don't
like chattiness and back okay well then
fine are you chatting don't fuck me yeah
you're no I'm not chatty Kathy but I'm
not going to be mute but I also think
it's more about about I think it's
taking me a long it's not about telling
him what to do it's just it's like same
with training dogs I don't mean to say
men or dogs that's not what I'm doing I
just mean on both sides guys saying what
they like and girl sing with just
positive reinforcement yeah positive
reinforcement you don't have to say what
doesn't work just say what is what yeah
what's saying working so if I'm like if
a guy's going down on me because I've
really like very rarely like loved to
when someone goes down on me like there
have been a few guys by the way my
favorite thing is when you tell a guy
that you don't come from oral and every
man is like challenge accepted wait do
you see me oh yeah because you're
revolutionary and eating pussy challenge
you're accepted they take out there
[Laughter]
[Music]
you pop in a mouth spreader
they're like
I mean but also I think that what I do
like is more that when a guy is into it
because he just loves pussy in his mouth
yeah that's awesome like dude
there was a guy who I hooked up with
literally ate pussy like he was a
lesbian like he ate pussy like it was
his absolute favorite thing and all he's
ever wanted to do his entire life is
eight pussy like it's that if you're
gonna eat pussy you eat it with that
level of enthusiasm or don't especially
if if he's able to like ascertain a
little bit of like oh I haven't showered
or oh no I haven't showered yet and he
just doesn't care oh no there was a guy
I dated a guy who I was like I would
come back from like a run and he'd be
like I'm eating her pussy right now and
I'd be like I just went for a run and
he's like I don't give a I feel like we
should do a podcast just for only fans
okay
I just that like that is such a genius
idea
um do women prefer great fingering over
sex some
some I mean I'm I have
um you know I I make jokes about it but
it really is true I think I have a
bigger vagina than most women by bigger
you mean deeper I think just deeper like
I can like you know I can like I can
really take a dick
um I I just it's like this it's one of
those things where it's like if I have
sex with a guy who has a small dick I'm
just like I'm not enjoying this you're
not enjoying this like it's not working
for either one of us it's not that I'm a
size queen I just like don't want this
to suck but what about doing it in your
tushy oh I like bad stuff if you have a
big dick though don't you no anything
that's near my fucking box I I think
people are always like are you an ass
girl do you like anal sex do you like
it's like for me it's based on this his
side yeah if a guy doesn't have a giant
dick I get kind of excited because I'm
like oh this could go in the butt I
totally yeah I'm gonna have to I'm not
gonna be able to have lasagna for dinner
but I'm gonna have to I have to start
planning at noon but I really enjoy anal
sex if it's not some like you know GMO
cock okay wait there's I just changed
one of my prompts on a dating app I just
changed my prompt to this oh God I have
to I have to play it so on hinge you can
do voice prompts and this was the voice
prompt that I I just selected for myself
uh-oh um all right the it's a voice
prompt on to show it to you so it's a
prompt where it's it asks you a question
and then you answer it so my voice
prompted says biggest risk I've taken
and this was my answer
fuck hold on oh
wait so oh oh like there's questions and
then you can answer it answer it
um verbally
I mean okay ready biggest risk I've
taken getting on hinge okay one time I
went out for Mexican food and later that
night I tried anal
oh
who's who's being serious on these
prompts oh that's funny that's really
funny this
this oh what are we doing that's really
endearing because I'm just like I'm just
like who is because there are men who
are answering the questions and they're
being like biggest risk I've ever taken
one time I went to Puerto Vallarta with
only like you know three guys and then I
got you know food poisoning I'm just
like who's answering these questions so
I was just like biggest worst I've ever
taken Mexican and anal nerd yeah and if
he doesn't find that funny then if he
doesn't find it funny then you're just
not my person oh do women really like to
give titty fuck you know you said that
you like that I like that too but my
boobs are fake so I can't I can't get
them I can't they aren't big enough to
wear like what I've seen in porn a dick
and then the the boobs will swallow it
those are the other side of the dick I
can't they're Eiffel towering the day I
can try but they kind of slide out like
that's why fake tits need a really big
but this is why also you just put your
hand over yeah
with your hands yeah
um uh but it's but here's the thing
you're not it's not like you're enjoying
the physical sensation it's you're
enjoying the visual of it I by the way
dated a guy once who his favorite thing
was me like lying on top like my head
would be on his stomach kind of and
lying on top of him and this is before I
had fake boobs I did not have big boobs
at all and he would kind of just like
like like
um what's the word like I guess like
from below like fuck on my chest just
fuck your sternum yeah
guys like I want to Bone you and he was
just fucking my atoms up in your bone
but like he and it was dry and I guess
something about the friction or
something I don't know I mean to each
his own you know to each his own yeah
everything it did it for him so it
really did and I don't know if it was
just like the looking down at me and me
being beneath him or something but yeah
there was something about that or maybe
he just wanted to find a way to be able
to be on the bottom and do as little as
possible I don't even know uh why does
it no big dick little dick I mean I
facial's okay
I love facials that's just coming on
your face that's getting cum on your
face but when he was like Whitney's like
does it have anti-aging problems I would
say so you put babies in a blender yeah
and then put it but so that is I I like
it where when I ask for it I don't know
if I want a surprise because have you
ever got cum in your eye for real yeah
and been stuck in England I mean if
there's one scenario I would love it's
come in my eye and I'm just landlocked I
you know those little things those
little glass things that you look like
you could put an egg on them but they're
actually to flush your eye I had to get
one of those from boots in England I
almost had to get an eye patch because
come like went in my eye I don't think
I'd ever had come in my eye like that
before but you wear glasses so you're
set no I mean I'm not fucking with my
glasses on that's good
but those glasses the kind of glasses
you had to wear in chemistry class
um no you you got you must have gotten a
really like nasty load stuck in your eye
because I've gotten come in my eye
before and it's been bad but it has oh
the vegans come in your eyes yeah yeah
the legumes they build up too much acid
and they come I just like you have to
know what you're doing because I think
the main thing is if you miss uh
fantastically I never want to have to
pretend so if your ropes have come are
totally going past my face and I have to
be like huh I have to try to get them so
that you feel more like I like you
better just fucking nail it get a voodoo
doll for your bedroom whatever yeah
like look know where you're going yeah
you know because I think sometimes guys
are trying to figure it out practice
practice makes perfect I also think it's
helpful to do it instead of having sex
with a girl you're about to come and
then thrusting up and having to do the
like one-legged man uh reverse uh what
is it remember the crab walk up to it
yeah yeah because then I have to go down
just when you're close to coming then
just jerk off until it happens that is a
choreography thing if a guy does the
pull out and then wants to come on your
face like you better be able to move
quickly and I better know the moves to
get down exactly like this is a big
fussy verdict yeah yes so this is what
you're talking about we're just too
Lemmy yeah it's gonna be clumsy and
clumsy if you're willing for it to be
clumy and klutzy like yeah great that's
fine but like that's a long we're long
yeah yeah like for a guy to go like from
here to like that's a fucking Journey
like you're going to Mecca yeah yeah so
I would say don't do it right when
you're about to come because then you
have to hustle up and then you've got
this like Blair Witch Project Trail of
Tears up to my you know just a snail
Trail just like
um how many times a week do the fingers
straighten the pussy
what I mean I think that's how many
times do you masturbate I don't
understand okay there are a lot of
people a lot of women I love how
creative guys like to get I've read some
of these answers some of you guys are
trying way too fucking hard my favorite
one that I read was what that mouth do
honestly honestly talks and makes money
that's what her mouth does someone asked
I mean look
um it makes men all over the world
flaccid what can I say uh I do think a
lot of people are asking what can help
to improve your sex drive let's talk
about that but number two what's the
kinkiest thing you've ever done and per
what you just said because sometimes
guys try to over complicate it so much
like I just like like I feel like I'd be
hanging from a meat hook if some guys
had their way you know and so um like do
I have to dress like Harley Quinn like
can I to me the kinkiest thing you can
do at this point is missionary
I think the hottest thing I this is the
space I'm in right now I'm in a
tank top still on I'm just imagining you
by the way dressed as Harley Quinn right
now and like honestly like not terrible
not I mean honestly super hot I think
the hottest thing you can do right now
and maybe it's just because I'm a very
busy person and I appreciate someone
that respects my time is tank top still
on
underwear to the side socks still on
missionary get it done underwear to the
side underwear what a fucking no time no
time
loving underwear to the side just no
time to take draws off
um that's hot but that's like missionary
It's like because I mean otherwise it's
like always got to be some circulation
and I'm like also there's something
about missionary where it's like if if I
say I want you to fuck me you fuck me
yes and that's missionary and by the way
big hot tip pillow under the uh yeah
pillow under the tush yeah is key yeah
little elevation yeah or pick it up
either way yeah like if you're a strong
guy pick my fucking ass up wild but like
yeah missionaries missionaries fucking
great missionary honestly like it's I
mean it's it's a tried and true position
it you know there's it's like um
it's like the uh
you know Hawaiian Tropic of sunscreens
it's like sometimes you got to just be
like you know what I don't need the
mineral that like just yeah give me the
ogf8f8 yeah SPF oil for when you want to
burn and not get cancer
um but I do love I do one of the things
I don't love when missionary is when
guys just you I need you to Lean Forward
on me a little bit please because then
you get the clitoral stimulation yeah
some guys will just do the whole like
off the side like just the the thrust
yeah it's just like you're you're not
I'm not there's not enough clitoral
stimulation like you have to have the
angle where you're like rubbing a little
bit again yeah but then they have to
kind of Plank and the problem is
sometimes black guys are terrible at
fucking because they're never on top
yeah you know and some guys saw guys are
terrible at fucking because they're hot
and they've never had to try for
anything in their life I remember Anna I
did a movie with some famous musicians
and we had a sex scene and I was so
intimidated because I love that you just
were like some musicians like the Foo
Fighter well I remember I just was like
so intimidated dated because I was like
you know like he's been with so many
women and I'm like making fun of him
like you've slept with like thousands of
women did you just scene with Rami yes
oh you're funny
and no one is hotter he's the greatest
the sweetest he's wearing like beads so
I'm like this guy has fucked you know
fucked like you're wearing bracelets and
Beads like that's how hot you can get
away with that and you just get hotter
with every weird Crystal you have
hanging from your neck and uh and I'm
like I'm gonna be on the bottom I'm like
what if I like don't come off gutted sex
even though obviously we're faking it
and he was on top and it was I was dying
because he was so awkward about it and I
was like you're a rock star like how are
you so he's like I'm always on the
bottom rock stars never have to be on
this that is so funny he's also an old
friend of mine the best thing Romy has
ever said ever in the history of the
world I go Romney what's the difference
between you now and when you were
younger he's like well when I was
younger I was a dirty hippie he's like
now I'm just a rich dirty hippie and I
was like best answer ever oh he's just
greatest do you like your ass eaten um
really
okay so walk me through it because I'm
it's I maybe I just haven't I mean I
don't need you to spend time down there
but like it's just you're just it's so
animalistic I just don't I've never been
like this is worth the herosis coming up
of like what if I fart well then you
fart who gives a fuck like if he's down
there it's the business end like he
knows I actually I'm pretty nasty when
it comes to like if your fingers are
inside me sure Jam I'm in my mouth
whatever I don't know if I wanted you to
kiss me after you've eaten my ass if
I'll be honest I ride a lot of horses I
mean it's just I you know what I'm
saying yeah I don't want to need
Ivermectin after we hook it I mean there
is there's an element of like once you
eat my butt then we're just doing anal
and then that's over I mean oh God
getting your butt eaten for me is like
that's the next step to anal because
like you're not fucking me in the butt
unless you've you know loosened it up
with some bud eating but let me ask you
though what what is your go-to because I
feel like guys
like I guess I do the same thing that
annoys me the guys do is like is if a
guy's were having sex missionary or
whatever it is go to cradle the balls
right and then but sometimes guys will
be weird about it and you're like oh I
thought this was like an every guy thing
to just like lightly cradle their balls
yeah while they're hugging you yeah and
then using your maybe middle finger to
push up on their prostate yeah right but
then sometimes you try to sneak your uh
finger into their butt and some guys are
not into it yeah how do you know you I
feel like that's a conversation to find
out otherwise he'll just like be like a
bucking bronco no it's just like don't
yeah no no have that conversation yeah
but do you know a lot of guys that are
not into that or if they maybe they just
here's my problem at this point because
I have nails so I'm not putting my nails
that's I'm not gonna perforate a fucking
wreck yeah no no you can't Edward
Scissorhand yeah I can't Edward scissors
uh no so it's like every to me it's just
like sex is better when it's just like
there's a bit of a conversation there's
a bit of an understanding also like have
a couple shots and just be like what are
you in into what are you into also butt
plugs are out there now they have so
many butt plugs I have like I don't know
a lot of butt plugs so it's just like we
can all have a butt plug so okay but
I've never had sex with a guy with a
butt plug-in I don't know if I could do
it no I've had sex with a guy with when
he had a butt plug in once and then I've
I've had sex with a butt plug-in
multiple times I like having sex with
the butt plug-in yeah but
I'm not totally sure if it's for him or
for me but I don't care like it's the
idea to make your pussy smaller because
the plugs in there pushing it up there's
you know there's a little more pressure
it's like you have a Neighbor Next Door
so yeah it makes your studio apartment a
little bit smaller I just referred to my
pussy as a studio apartment
um it makes it a little bit smaller but
it's just like it's a whole pressure
thing and there's just like a lot of
nerve endings down there so it's just
like it just feels good yeah I don't
know if I need a guy to have a butt
plugin that would bum me out like
personally but I mean I'm happy to do
that listen if that's what it is that
does it for you but like we're not both
plugging up on the regular so what uh uh
um I don't know what to say to people
who have low sex drive like I actually
think I have a pretty low sex drive when
I'm not actively dating or sleeping with
someone I don't really think about it
that much I'm not like I just need some
dick like I'm just not that person but
when I'm with someone I have a high sex
drive yes when I'm with someone I want
to have sex all the time yeah but but
I'm not I don't think it's I think yeah
it's not abnormal to not be
it goes a little dormant like it's just
and everybody's different but one thing
I there are a lot of like natural things
that can increase your sex drive working
out increases your sex drive
um maca root
um it's a a root macaroot Google it um
red maca root no you can get maca root
pills
um red macaroon increases your sex drive
I've tried that
um I mean I mean but why do we need to
increase our sex drive if we're not at
you know I see if you're in a
relationship why you'd want to but why
do we have to over pathologize that I'm
so so to that person I'm just wondering
are you in a relationship and you're
just not able to like maybe your partner
doesn't do it for you in that case in
that case it's like I don't know we just
came out in the pandemic we couldn't
even be six feet I just feel like sex
drive in general like fluctuates like
there's extra fluctuates and I think
that's the most important takeaway of
all of it is sometimes I just feel gross
yeah what Pat
um yeah lack of libido I think that my
like my sex size Drive is going up I
started doing those peptides and they
increased your testosterone like a tiny
bit yes
um that's been big but like sometimes I
just feel sick I'm like next time I have
sex I'm coming over here to get a
peptide to try it
um should couples schedule intimacy
that's interesting absolutely a thousand
percent thousand percent if that's the
problem in your relationship schedule it
schedule it if it's not happening
naturally then that's your only other
put the dog in the crate put the dog in
the crate get a babysitter for the kids
schedule the time to be sexual because
if it's not happening you're gonna have
to schedule it period like I'm sorry
it's it's the the the spontaneity of sex
isn't happening anyways so then just
figure out a new thing to do yes because
you're always going to find excuse or I
think for me it's not about just I know
the things that make me feel insecure
that make me not want to have sex like
if I haven't you know like shaved or
groomed in the way I need if I haven't
shaved my legs like there's things that
I know are gonna make me not feel sexy
or not be into it so like I just get
ahead of that scheduling that too yeah
like the self-care that makes you want
to have sex in the first place yeah
um uh I have so much there's so we have
to do a part two on this
um something men should know about sex
that women won't usually tell us
that we're so confused by uncircumcised
dicks and they're fine but we sometimes
we just need help and you have to clean
them yeah yeah guys clean your by the
way I've dated a guy who did not clean
his dick well and I would just get
YouTube UTI after UTI after UTI and it
was just like and a lot of times if a
new person you're with is not having sex
with you or avoiding sometimes like in
when I was in my 20s like if I got a UTI
and was dating someone I would just
ignore them I wouldn't want to tell them
feelings but I also didn't know I didn't
want them also I was like oh am I gross
is he yes like who which one is the
gross person why did this happen and I
would just try to avoid them until it
was over so a lot of times with UTIs
I'll I'll share this this I know for
sure because I get UTIs a lot because if
you have sex with guys who have bigger
dicks it's literally this is how the
urologist described it to me he goes the
guy is knocking things loose
so he's like so imagine there's just
debris and dust on something and when
you walk if there's debris on Dust on
the wall behind you if I hit the wall it
would knock some of the debris and dust
loose so he's like it's the same thing
with a vagina he's like on the outside
of your vagina he's like unless you wash
right before you have sex and unless he
washes right before he has sex he's like
there is bacteria in the area he's like
and then that gets into the urethra he's
like so he's like when the bigger the
dick the more he's Gonna Knock things
loose and you have to pee right away and
I mean right out that's why that's why
the whole squirting thing isn't so bad
because I'm peeing while we're having
sex ah genius and then always have the
UTI meds standing by just like have them
like there's a pillow you can take
there's a pillow you can take before you
have sex if you have chronic UTIs which
I take I can't even remember the name
because you're also going to enjoy sex
more when you're like okay if I don't
pee enough afterwards if he forgot to
wash his hands or had a hangnail or
whatever if like you know I have it
standing by because I think that like it
makes me not enjoy because I'm like okay
this is enough like I don't know if you
washed his hands and I stopped enjoying
it if I have to think about it how do I
get a girl to orgasm with a two inch
cock
let me know toys are everywhere those
toys I never I don't Chelsea Lynn
trailer trash Tammy introduced me to sex
I had never used a sex toy in my life
until like a year ago during the
pandemic because they started sending me
them
um and they work so well that I
literally was like I can't use these
anymore because I can see myself getting
completely addicted oh yeah I went
through a massive addiction don't just
don't get addicted it's not a good
situation they work too well yeah they
work too well
um uh yeah the whole two inch dick thing
um they make so many sex toys for
extending the length of your dick go to
uh the well I mean wherever you are I
mean in la there's the pleasure Chest
but there are there's a whole company
called um I think it's called mega fit
um but they make sex toys for men with
small penises huh it's a sheath that you
put over your deck it's called there's a
big boy and the fat boy oh right and
it's you literally put it over your uh
over your penis
what's a rim job exactly that's when you
like fascinating yeah hmm like that
reminds me of a joke I wrote from the
long time when I went to when I went to
um uh the Grand Canyon there's a there's
the south rim I'm like if you work on
the south rim do you have a rim job
so dumb but it makes me giggle I um
what's the kinkiest thing a guy's ever
done to you we were like whoa
yes please you know what I'll tell you
mine yeah is like choking can be it is I
love love love but like It's tricky
because I know guys are you know they
like it's a it's a fine line you have to
kind of do it the perfect way and at the
perfect time and if you're trepidatious
about it it's not hot you know but if
I'm actually trying to have an orgasm
you can do it too much and I can't
breathe but you know and then it's like
I don't know I mean
the oxygen restriction I I feel like I
have that unlock when I'm masturbating I
know how to hold my breath to make it
more intense I don't totally know how to
do it with someone else choking me like
you know but
by the way if someone's choking you you
have to lean into the choke yeah and let
them know yeah so it's but it's like but
you there's also like you need to like
guide their hand because if you choke
higher than then there's a low choke and
there's a high choke and if you're
dating someone that is a medical
professional uh sometimes they do this
because they actually know how to really
choke someone um that's so funny wait
that I remember when your your ex we
were talking about this he's like yeah
if I was gonna choke you I would choke
you like no I know one time I said like
choke me or something he went like and I
was like whoa okay I think that's like
actually the the correct way to kill
someone by shattering their windows I
just meant like uh like a silly goose
joke but I I'm into an arm bar I'm into
just an arm over the neck too yeah an
arm over the neck and like cradling the
head somebody's fucked an MMA fighter
fucking yeah I what I I have whispered
sweet nut things into a cauliflower here
yeah once or twice but that I kind of
like because it's like very dominant but
you're not dealing with this awkwardness
of it's choking properly is he too
trepidatious am I a like whore and am I
gonna die soon yeah I like an arm bar
and I like and I also like a a um uh
legs over the shoulders so if your legs
are on either side of his head he's
fucking you like in a way that is like
borderline misogynist and then kisses
your name
[Laughter]
like sprinkling in the little tender
things yeah fucking a girl's brains out
and then just kissing her in the front
of the forehead oh just a little thing
just a little kiss my head goes all the
way by the way that the the legs on the
side of the head up and a kiss on the
knee I know
it buys you it buys you a lot um oh I
love that so and by the way if the thing
we talked earlier because I just want to
make sure I don't um uh not tell you if
you're coming on a girl's face coming on
all that stuff you get up and you get a
towel go you are fucking set set by the
way one of my favorite things to do I
call it the spa treatment after we have
sex if because like I have to get up to
go pee sometimes I'll like grab a
washcloth and I'll put like hot water on
it and like get it like nice and warm
and toasty and then I'll come back and
I'll like wrap his dig up like a little
bit like I'll swaddle like E.T when they
try to smuggle them out of the house and
I'll just I'll wrap up the whole I'll
put the shaft in there I'll get the nuts
in there too the whole thing just a full
body wrap up that's interesting because
I am scared to touch a guy's dick after
he comes because I think that I made a
couple mistakes sucking guy's dick
longer after he came but it gets so
sensitive by the way some guys like it
some guys don't know that is a
case-by-case basis huh there's some guys
like once he once he comes it's like
don't fucking touch myself yeah yeah
um but every guy if you wait long enough
you can you could wrap it up and swaddle
it no but every guy likes that so much
oh my God the last guy I was with was
just like oh my God thank you so much I
was like it's these spot treatment I was
like now we go to shower and you wash my
boobs but uh yes love that A Little
Tenderness goes a long way and it's sex
it's not about just as soon as it's over
like you still stick The Landing go get
a towel Yeah clean it up be respect
that's still part of it yes that is
still part of it by the way wet do not
bring Kleenex I don't want you fucking
decoupaging my body with toilet paper as
it falls apart on the drying come you
know what else I like because there's
something really awkward to me a lot of
it is about the foreplay and the after
play and I don't mean four players and
we have to make out for 45 minutes yeah
so Nora Jones like I'm not even saying
that it's more like
when you know you're about to have sex
with someone or hook up with someone and
you're downstairs or you're at the car
and you're walking and you know like I
like a guy who will give you a piggyback
ride
yeah it's just like something where it's
like because you the awkward moment
where like you're leading and he and
he's kind of not and you're kind of like
oh am I initiating this too much like I
like something that's a non-verbal Alpha
I got you type of thing that's just
picking me up I feel fat and I feel
weird and you're gonna you're gonna
break my achilles going through the door
comfortable yeah but like something like
that that is so Primal and weird
I'm very into where you'd make it so I
don't have to feel like a horror because
because I have to give you permission to
so I have to be leading and I think guys
now less want to be less aggressive but
I like there's something sweet and hot
there's something consensual about it
piggyback yes because there's something
conceptual thing to jump on your back
yeah and you're carrying me and it's
like everything that needs to be said
has been said yes yes that is very it's
also very like uh it's like silly and
childlike and like it incorporates I
think I guess it's a fun koala a front
cover if you are big enough to front
koala me and then walk me in and then
it's like everything has already been
said yeah we both know what's about to
happen yeah and I'm just like oh have
your way with me I'm so aware of God
please because I don't like having to
lead a guy to the you know and then it's
just like you're like let me show you my
bedroom like you're in fucking high
school you want to see my bedroom
because then you're sort of like are we
doing this are we not like I've
consented in a way that's like hot and
you have already dominated me in a way
that I'm like in yeah oh I love it all
of this oh my God oh my God I'm so
obsessed with you okay I'm so horny I'm
just the horny I'm so horny just like
it's like it's just like soft all I want
to do I just first of all I feel like
I'm such a better person like I'm going
through a breakup right now and like he
and I talked last week for a second well
your DMs are about to be flooded with
eggplants by the way don't do that guys
that's so weird
um but I just like the I just think it's
like I'm such a better person when I'm
having sex like I really just am like
don't you feel like
the less come you have in your body the
better you're doing I think there's that
but I also think that I used to be a
worse person because I feel insecure
after I hated my body I was like was
that good was that not I felt I had set
myself up to be exploited or violated I
didn't know what my own boundaries were
I didn't know what made me feel good I
would disassociate because I was like
had sexual abuse like it's only recent
yeah that afterwards I'm like or like if
a guy's having sex with me and I'm like
looking down so I like to watch a guy
like I kind of like I like to like watch
out yeah but like now I'm like getting
old like my skin I have like more yeah
you know it's not as tall yeah and the
fact that I can look at that and be like
this is so this is even hotter yeah that
he's that he's so into me and I'm not
like you know I have like whatever the
wrinkle stomach I have imperfections
totally and like I I haven't shaved my
pubes perfectly so I have little
Smithers hairs and he doesn't care like
that I'm into like I think that like
when I was trying to make sex so perfect
and aesthetically like porn or whatever
like it would it was always like all
that work for that yeah like you know
yeah and now when you watch a guy Be So
Into You when you're not even at your
most groomed or your most perfect or
your most whatever then I'm like I love
sex oh that's the best this is so fun
yeah you know and I I feel like I just
in the last like five years really
started like seriously enjoying sex for
real not being like I have to be really
good at this you know for a guy and I
get off on just being real him getting
off you know it's like it's like guys
holding a person Nordstrom it's like
they know they have to do it but it's
not like they're not in they're getting
off on the fact that you're happy you
know but I just recently started being
like Oh I'm gonna get mine and I'm gonna
leave every sexual encounter feeling
better about myself I want that for
every woman I really do like when when I
hear that women like don't like love sex
and don't oh don't feel just like super
like sexual and powerful and beautiful
when they're having sex it like really
like breaks my heart but I also think
it's it's in order to me I get real
really I'm really into being degraded
degraded dominated whatever sexually but
when I was degrading myself all day
every day
outside of sex yeah it's not as fun when
you actually have low self-esteem and
then you're degrading yourself or
allowing someone to degrade you now that
I'm in a place where I like have
self-esteem and self-worth yeah it's fun
because it's like we're taking this
little trip where we pretend that that's
also like the degrading kind of sex
that's also like again that's a
conversation like that's something that
that's a version of sex that doesn't
happen to have to happen all the time
like a guy being like you little fucking
slut like don't call me a little fucking
slut all the time but like sometimes
call me a little fucking slut you know
like it's it's one of those things where
it's like it can't be one way all the
time yeah throw in the variation and
it's like but yeah sometimes you're
you're very hard on yourself so you
don't want someone else to be hard on
you and like it's your sex has evolved
and the way you see yourself is evolved
yeah and I also think it's like the kind
of thing it's like you know and I'm
gonna say this word Don't Panic everyone
but like you don't call someone who has
Down syndrome retarded that's not funny
no you know what I mean that's just mean
you know that's just shitty yeah but
like when you degrade someone one who
has no self-esteem that's not hot that's
not hot that's gross then you're just
playing into what they already feel
about themselves and it's hurtful
totally and now that I have my shit
together and I know who I am now it's an
active choice to be degraded and it's
like really fun because it's not like
permanent and it's not like oh I'm not
I'm never confused if this is really my
value yeah you know what I'm saying it's
like I'm now strong enough to be able to
be weak by choice and it's like a hot
Cosplay thing so it's like I used and I
know so many girls were like yeah in bed
I just get on top and I fucking own them
and I'm like I do not that is not what I
do that all day every day in my work
life I'm On Top all the time yeah you
know and the shit that turns me on now
is like guys knowing my status
professionally or the way that I move
through the world and then we get into
the bedroom and I go to get on top and
he's like no no no no you've been doing
that no no you don't need to do that now
no no but every now and then it's fun
too yeah
like sometimes like I'm I'm dominant in
my own life and sometimes sexually like
I like to be on top by the way this is
um just in in the uh spirit it was like
a funny thing embarrassing the most
embarrassing thing that ever happened to
me during this accident
is like I was because I think we are
Comics too so we generalize we see sort
of sometimes the worst version of people
we hang out with a certain kind of guy
certain kind of girl and I forget
sometimes like that a lot of men like
love women and just really respect them
and think they're to be taken care of
and cherished and chivalry one time I
was like and it's honestly the younger
guys are the ones I find I don't know
maybe it's because they grew up with
Oprah and Beyonce yeah and you know they
just have a lot of tools in their
toolbox totally like and they didn't
grow up with like Kate Moss going like
women are supposed to like be you know
sick and you know feeble and you know
nothing tastes as good as thin feels
okay exactly like every woman should or
it just should be trafficked or whatever
so uh I was just so used to degrading
myself because those are the kind of
guys that you know I dated were the ones
that that's what they got off on a woman
that already their girl that already
didn't have self-esteem degrading
herself and being degraded like that's
like you know that's a calling someone
with Down Syndrome retarded it's like
you know hat on a hat and so uh I was
talking about this younger guy really
sweet very there's a lot of Romantics
out there there's a lot of real sweet
younger hopeless Romantics they grew up
on porn and they're like I saw that the
other thing about these younger guys
um they grew up playing hardcore video
games which I think a lot of people like
videos games bad a lot of it is like the
the noble medieval White Knight cosplay
where they want to be heroes and they're
in like the medieval uh Dynamic of it is
my job to rescue and protect but women
were like I can open my own fucking door
I'll drive to the restaurant you know
like didn't know I did this in the video
game I want to do this yes they're like
this is what I got a lot of times they
want to save the day you know I mean I
know Call of Duty is a lot of guns but
it's also about I'm saving the day yeah
protecting women and children a lot of
them like want that Valor and that honor
you know and so uh I
um hooking up with this guy as we talked
about before pretty good at blow jobs
have the whole you know choreography
down I go down uh we're just like making
out I go down and I'm like I'm gonna
blow this guy's mind real quick go down
like choke on his cock and he goes whoa
whoa whoa whoa and I was like what he
goes uh I just I'm not really into women
hurting themselves
I I was like uh I literally tears coming
down my eyes and I'm like huh like your
mascara is just like running down your
face I this is like six years ago I mean
I'm pretty successful at the time he's
like an aspiring actor he's like oh no
no can I I'm just not into that oh it
was no oh that's so awkward oh my pussy
would close up shot first of all I'm
also in his two-bedroom apartment that
he shares with a roommate I leave my
house where I'm like running a show and
I was like yeah and he was like uh
he was like sweetie sweetie oh my God I
can't wait to find out who this is it
was kind of a turning point for me yeah
because I was like oh this is sad yeah
it's not hot to him it's sort of a
bummer yeah it was a bummer and he like
he like just stopped everything that was
happening did you at least laugh about
this at some point oh it was so much
afterwards okay yeah he was like so fine
but he just was like this just you know
he wanted to just like kiss and hold my
face and I was like that and he was just
like oh honey honey I don't want to
commit a crime by accident I really just
kind of want to fuck you like can I
please just put my dick in your pussy oh
God I love this so much that is a moment
that has to be in a and it's so in a
movie you have to make that because I
think girls also we are watching porn
too and we're going ah fuck me yeah and
then guys like hold on hold on we just
went from zero to a hundred you don't
respect you I respect you yeah that but
there are sometimes like I'll watch porn
and I'll be like oh my god I've I've
come at a guy this aggressively before
because I saw it in a porn yeah and I
think this is what they want us to just
be like come whores I'm your slut yeah
yeah fucking hold on loads on loads like
are you do we need to get you a snorkel
like you're not breathing like that
sound I like I please keep get me out of
this crime scene like I did not sign up
for this sometimes I think I should get
a guy snorkel when I'm squirting I'm
like I'm sorry we're both underwater it
is really so didn't you ruin a hotel
mattress or something absolutely wrote
it we had to we had to take it off the
bed and then prop it up against the
sliding door so we could it could dry
overnight and then we'd just sleep on
the other bed
it was a two bedroom it was a two bed in
the yeah it was the fact that you do not
have a paid partnership with Saran Wrap
is shocking shocking
shocking Nicole might start a podcast on
what we're going to talk about this
offline too okay
um uh I think you should start a podcast
I mean I just I never want to hear
anybody talk you're one of the only
people I really do want to hear talk I
don't think anyone really needs to start
a podcast right now I think we need to
take a breather but you are one of the
few people where I'm like okay call her
daddy is so giant and to me you would be
just like the the
um you know just the what is what would
it be call her granddaddy call hold her
like call her grandma Grandma it's like
it's it's a it's a I think a different
tone entirely but I think she's also
moving more towards interviewing and
stuff now too more like Stern type but
it's just like
when someone is as smart as you as funny
as you as as
um self-aware as you I'm like I would
usually tell people to not start podcast
I'm trying to figure out how to stop
doing a podcast yeah I love that you
want to stop doing a podcast you're so
good at it shut the fuck up I that that
is very nice you say that I can at all
times and like why am I doing this I
cannot like
I do not feel like I'm great at it but
whatever I feel like you're good I also
think you should start a podcast Network
and I should be your first you know what
that's what God it's like I'm really
good at knowing who should have a
podcast yeah even if I'm not that good
at it myself but I do think I guess the
whole thing about podcast is being
imperfect and I think that part of the
charm of this one is people go like you
know this episode's kind of boring and
I'm like this is kind of boring and like
well at least she knows yeah like she
interrupts a lot and I'll be like I'm
sorry I interrupt a lot it's like well
Lucy like the charm of like how are you
perfect at podcasting the only thing
more annoying than someone not being
that great at it is someone who's like I
fucking ruled drop the mic at fucking
pocket yeah you're you're I love your
very good at interviewing you're you're
not only an interesting person but
you're also interested and I think
that's what makes your podcast great but
when I'm not interested I change the
subject because I this is Howard Stern
said this a lot I remember him saying
this a long time ago someone asked him I
think I was on the show when someone had
asked him because I didn't really they
listen to it as religiously as a lot of
other people I didn't grow up on Stern
you know but
um he people said like how do you know
how to interview because he'll pivot
really hard he'll be like so you are you
in therapy and you later so did you when
you were working Jack Nicholson you
fucked him right yeah and then he'll be
like oh so what do you like eat like are
you you know he'll jump around and he
basically says if I'm getting bored that
means the audience is getting bored so
for me when I interrupt someone or
whatever it means I don't know what
they're saying what they're saying isn't
clear enough I want to like make sure
the table is set yeah so I'm just I mean
I could just let the person blather on
and cut it later but then you're gonna
hear a weird cut yeah to me the times
that I interrupt is really just to go
like let's pick a new Direction yeah and
like trust me yeah we're Comics like we
know when things are going south yeah I
so when I had my old podcast the porn
podcast you know some of the porn stars
weren't that great of an interview yeah
um so it would be me like really like
bouncing around and I had like a million
topics that I wanted to cover but like I
would notice sometimes like like what
you just said like if I notice myself
getting bored and I was changing the
topic not because I was like I want to
make sure the audience is I was like I
can't be this bored like I can't allow
myself to go down the depths of this
like this isn't interesting anymore
let's try to find something new that's
interesting and also if I maybe it's my
OCD maybe other people don't struggle
with this but like when someone is
talking about something and I don't know
I I don't I have a question I can't
focus on anything else and you know yeah
so yeah I just need to work on not
interrupting and letting things play out
a little more I guess yeah like my
biggest fear in life is being boring
and so I panic when I think something's
boring you're like you're women's number
one thing they're afraid of being
murdered Whitney's number one thing that
she's afraid of being boring wouldn't
that be funny if like God forbid you're
being raped and you're like but oh my
God you're not bored are you
please tell me you're not bored you're
like notice that your rapist is bored
and you're like oh no this is the worst
this is my worst nightmare I feel like I
yeah I probably would be a pretty boring
person to rape one of my first jokes I
ever did this can get me in trouble I
don't give a shit but um I would say
like you know a woman's worried about
getting raped like the key to not
getting raped just don't say no
like just I'm unraveable like I would do
those weird little one-liners like that
but like we can't do those anymore I had
a joke about how um I feel like I'm so
annoying that you could never rape me
like a guy would just be like oh my God
I'm sorry I didn't ask so I got it never
mind you'd be like fuck
man and he'd be like I'd be like I'd be
like but what's going on how are you
doing have you talked to your mom lately
the idea that a rapist starts with you
and then you start squirting all over
him he's like God damn it he's like you
are a mess
ah who's gonna clean this up this is I
uh it is interesting I mean there we'll
talk about this next time but um there
is that kind of like rape fantasy thing
there's just this like dissonance in
society where it was like the me too
thing was happening consent was at its
all time like highest in terms of like
let's talk about consent and then
like rape porn was like you know I
remember Nikki said one time uh Glazer
said I think she was it was on some I
don't remember show with who's Jimmy
Carr and uh she said like in order for
me to come I have to watch I have to it
has to start with so I'm lost in a
warehouse
now like we're just at the at the time
we're like yes
consent is you know we're having this
conversation but also how do we uh
reconcile that with the party nothing to
be taken yes
it is I mean but it's just like
there are there are women who are going
to have that fantasy no by the way it's
a fantasy that's the other thing so when
people it's like that doesn't mean you
can't be super aggressive with a woman
you can't uh do those you know whatever
consensual rape fantasies but like
there's a difference and you know it so
when guys like well women love being
raped but they also now we have to ask
for permission it's like you know the
difference
and as a woman you shouldn't feel shame
for being down to be choked or having a
hand in your mouth or whatever because
we've the context clues are that it's
consensual by the way have you ever had
a guy do the thumb Hawk Where Are You
Like official yeah from behind
now you did that okay this is actually
the most embarrassing thing that's
happened to me in a long time oh this
was so you know when Annie Letterman has
a uh she was making master in the
pandemic and on the fabric was this the
pussy eating the pussy of pussy eating
which is this and I was we were trying
to write a joke about it and when I get
in joke brain I'm very I get very I'm on
one plane of Consciousness I'm not
really there's a lot of common sense I'm
just thinking about jokes and I said I
was like what's the thing where um uh
the universal sign for eating pussy what
is it
is that it
I was dead serious four fingers the
whole room died and Whitney's just
sitting there like fisting her mouth
basically like what was that what what
is that
Annie had on her ass what this is
sausage it was so casual like this
because I was trying to think of a joke
oh my God that was like the things I
have learned the hard way in a writer's
room from writers like I remember it was
the writer's room of the NBC sitcom and
uh I was trying to think of like a story
or a conflict between my character and
Crystal your character and I was like oh
what if oh what if they have an issue
because she's gonna go off for IUD and
he's like one of those guys that's
allergic to latex so he can't wear
condoms yeah
and everyone was like
I was like you know some guys like can't
wear condoms because they're allergic to
latex and everyone's like
oh no Whitney got lied to
oh it's like you know most guys just
can't wear condoms because it like gives
them like a rash or like a UTI and so
they just like have to do it right by
the way am I condoms hurt me don't they
hurt you they really they are not
comfortable I'm I this is a hot take and
I think this is something that makes me
attracted to a guy when I'm gonna hook
up with a guy because I don't do it
quickly I always make them take STD
tests and show me the results same same
I'm just like takers the condom thing is
like crazy to me yeah it's like if
you're in a jam but I don't have one
night stands I don't have like quick sex
like random I'm like like go get an STD
test I'll go get enough to show it to me
because now now it's hot to me that you
did that yeah you want to fuck me so bad
that you're willing to do that and now I
have to worry I don't get mad at you
later like I hear these horror stories
of friends of mine that got fucking anal
warts they're burning off anal warts
with the uh okay
just keep going get a test it's so easy
to get an STD test just go get it
and then it tells me everything I need
to know about you based on and I'll go
get one too fucking adults I'm into that
okay because then otherwise I'm worrying
yeah condoms what Pat
do you ever instruct someone to do that
and then they just don't get back to you
after I'm sure that's happened they
failed the test and they're like okay
wait you want to hear you want to hear a
funny story so I was with this guy once
and he was like yeah I just got a test
done
um and then like two weeks later he was
like he was like yeah this girl I was
dating she got a test done
um uh right before I was the girl I was
dating before you and then I said to him
I go wait a minute did you tell me you
got a panel done because you based it on
the fact that the girl you were sleeping
with before me had got a panel done
like she had gotten an STD test and then
he was sleeping with her so he counted
that as his STD test was when she
because she didn't have any problems she
didn't have anything so he was like well
then I must not have anything proxy test
yeah well chlamydia doesn't show up in
guys it's not detectable so I'm just
like I'm like I'm like so you lied to me
about taking a test no it'll show up
everything else I mean but he's not
sorry he doesn't have symptoms
HPV is the one a guy will have symptoms
of chlamydia
but oh but HPV he won't have symptoms he
won't have to test that sometimes they
have symptoms but most of the time they
don't it's like it's like the bats in in
Africa that carry disease yeah it
doesn't affect the bats they just fly
around with it and carry it right right
yeah I'm not doing I don't know how I've
made it this long I do not know how I
made it this song I'm not not because
I'm some crazy horror it was more
because in my 20s I was too insecure to
like really force a guy to be wear a
condom yeah I mean I don't I don't know
are you gonna get STDs with condoms like
I've got I have I've had HPV before so
I'm not like not fine and then what do
you take to get no it just goes away see
I by some miracle I had like a darwinian
impulse take over me I had 500 and you
got the vaccine I got the vaccine yeah
which I'm sure has its own weird side
effects you know who knows but I got the
three shots of the HPV vaccine before
the cutoff date of being 27 I didn't
even have health insurance yeah I just
like went to a clinic and had to pay in
cash yeah I don't know how it's it is
now I mean you know first of all it only
protects you from a certain range of of
HPV it protects you from the the worst
ones right but you can still get HPV but
it's just like I mean every single girl
I know who's you know it's crazy that
you got it it's the crazier thing is
like working in
um uh TV and stuff you have to kiss so
many guys you know and I I remember
there was a guy that I was working with
who would have like canker sores and I
was like and I had to go this is what
human resource like HR can be really
annoying with like you can't say that
and you can't put a you know have a ball
sack on the back of your car at work or
whatever the ship truck nuts but like
truck nuts you just described truck nuts
by the way who in L.A has had truck nuts
dude I was just in Sacramento and in the
Sacramento it's a truck nuts town
and I was there was an HR like a
comedian's dream the person the front
room like what do you do she's like I
work in Human Resources I'm like ah tell
me everything and I said I was like
what's the most recent issue you've had
and she was like uh um people putting
dildos on other people's cars at work is
a joke and I was like that was hilarious
I would like to apply for a job at your
company but
going to HR to say like I do not want to
kiss this person because I I do not if
I'm gonna get herpes it's not gonna be
from some fucking actor no that I'm not
even dating yeah you know from you know
I'm not for the got it from it's from
Robert Redford yeah I so I you go in and
you get checked and then the actor has
to go on Valtrex it's like a whole thing
but then you kind of have to just change
the scene so that it's like something
else so sometimes when you see weird
kissing in movies where it's just like
they're like next to each other and then
it cuts to a sex scene it's like like a
lot of these guys have and women have
like herpes I'm like I'm not again no no
no you have to kiss 50 times wow no no
no no and I'm like I'm not doing this
the most fun thing I've ever had to do
is in a scene with a guy is acting as I
got to slap a guy repeatedly uh it was
the best the best day of my life on set
ever hard it wasn't even a soft slap it
was a full I got to unload on him that
but you had like a stunt coordinator
there no there was no sound Corner this
is a student film that's wild yeah so
it's a documentary yeah
there's like that's just abuse that was
caught on here it was so fun and then by
the way I ran into the guy maybe like
three or four years ago and he was like
I was the guy you were hitting on set
and I was like oh my God amazing super
hot guy oh man
um okay I love you I'm I'm I'm I'm and
he's awkwardly
um we're gonna do a round two of this uh
we're just gonna be doing like uh sex in
the call yeah we can make an ongoing
it's because it's like it's the kind of
thing where it's like I feel weird when
just like actresses are married male
Comics come on I'm just like so you
squirting like I feel like we should
just do sex episodes you know this is
what we're gonna talk about and we're
not just going from like with the war in
Ukraine's crazy so make sure by the way
the war in Ukraine very crazy it is very
great but you want to know what no
matter how bad the war is there I
guarantee there's still a couple at
night who's like you know what you want
to have like really fucking just dirty
ass sex I know we're in the middle of a
fucking that is going on there yeah yeah
must be wild no matter what people be
fucking yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we
have to figure this out because I need
new hair extensions in the Russian I
stand with Ukraine yeah yeah please for
the love of God get windy hair because I
can see her hair growing out it's
getting can you see yeah it's like no
it's not it's not that back to Blue it's
not that bad I will only do brown if
it's long thick locks like this by the
way you make me wanna get extensions
they're
they're they're they're they're
not cheap but the amount of money I save
and the amount of time I save and not
having to do the dice and dryer because
by hair when I don't have this in I feel
like I have to style it perfectly I'm
destroying it I'm inhaling like Aqua Net
all morning I'm burning it off like I
feel like you save money and time by
doing this even though it's like kind of
a pretty penny I save money looks it
looks so good I just want to be able to
put in a bun that doesn't just look like
a little hemorrhoid yeah oh my God mine
looks like an anal fissure like I just
it's a wee little bun or like the best
is when you're like you walk into a room
and you you have such little hair that
you I mean and then when you just you
have but you have none of your back just
so hotter so when you turn around you
have yeah you're like just
[Music]
yeah you know and like when your hair
gets wet mine when I don't it's a little
rat tail it's just like I it's it's it's
solved a problem for me emotional
problem you have to know happiness is an
inside job you have to know what is
going to solve your emotional problem
this actually solved an emotional
Problem by the way there's there's so
many things you do that I love the most
but one of my favorite things that you
do is like when you're talking about
something and you're like getting it to
the point of the the the what you're the
statement you're trying to make is like
a lesson you've learned you immediately
go into like an amazing 12-step slogan
where you're like you're like do you
want to be right or do you want to be
happy like you're whatever your mother's
not because they deserve forgiveness
because we deserve peace
I love it I'm the most like
um uh like inner work but elderly also
can be superficial person and I'm fine
doing both of them my favorite thing my
favorite thing is is when you had
finished shooting
um your roast you were like you were
like you found out I was going through a
breakup and you were like listen you're
like you're like oh my God I'm like
you're like in this like power Zone
you're like listen if you want to talk
we can like go over anything like call
me tomorrow like you're just like very
like you really like you you are like
very business-minded like at all times
but you're also like this like wildly
loving person who like wants to
make time to really be there for people
and I think that's so awesome I don't
believe in caretaking adults before you
try to solve a problem first make sure
it's your problem but I also know that
the kind of people that I love and I
know you well enough to know that you
wouldn't be here if you weren't okay and
so I know that you're okay because I
know you're always going to take care of
yourself but going like
um I would like to uh be supportive of
you in this we can't do it right now but
when we have time showing like as women
we can still have shit hit the fan in
our personal lives and still function
our professional lives and we're not
going to be derailed by relationships
and Men anymore but we still will find
the time to make sure that yeah I show
up for you as a friend and that's why
like when it happened at the beginning
of the week I knew it was going to be
like a crazy week and I was like it was
one of those things where it was like I
knew I wanted to talk to you about it
but I knew it was a crazy week and I'm
like this can wait I can I can talk to
her about this later I know she'll be
there for me later and I just love that
you like you really do try to hold space
for people as much as you can and it's a
really beautiful thing and I just wanted
to thank you for that I love you and I
love to be able to say to someone I'm
here if you you want to talk about it
at all I want to talk about something
different yeah like I'm here for all
versions yeah yeah you know but I also
am not the person who you know when like
a kid falls and like you know I was just
with a friend of mine's kids when a kid
falls the number goes oh we gotta do it
like yeah that's gonna make the kids
that's not gonna make any that's gonna
it's not gonna help I know that you're
okay but I also know that we need to
show up for each other and that there's
going to be some unpacking to do and I
know that I can like be of service but
it really bothers me when I you know I'm
going through a breakup or something I
was like oh my God are you okay yeah oh
God yeah you're 40. you're never gonna
find anyone like the level of sympathy
you have is actually kind of insulting
number one that you don't think I'm
gonna be able to bounce back from this
and number two that you think that I'm
like a puddle of Tears on the floor that
can't function yeah you know could agree
more I love email thanks I love you I
love you Nicole Amy Schreiber Instagram
Nicole Amy Schreiber Nicole Amy
Schreiber uh and I Nicole n i c o l e a
i m e on all social media and then and
just go to who I follow yeah and then at
the um end of December I'm in on 27th
I'm at the punch line in San Francisco
amazing uh 20 29th 30th I'm at the punch
line in Sacramento sick and then Cobbs
on New Year's Eve back in San Francisco
yeah I'm super excited that is gonna be
so fun I'm so jealous yeah so fun with
Doug Benson and Lori kilmartin and Louis
Katz yeah it's gonna be heaven heaven
because I remember you were taking a
little break from stand up yeah I'm back
yeah um I love it you're gonna be seeing
way more of Nicole Amy also uh she is
producing the only fans Ross that we're
making that are gonna be coming out in
January so you're gonna see that too I
love you guys don't ride elephants bye
[Music]
all right
[Applause]